Start recording
should be.
Yeah.
Okay.
How do I even begin this one?
The engine has been a very,
a fascinating thing for me in the,
you know,
many years that I've been on it,
but one of the most fascinating things about it as the ability to get in touch
with people that if you were younger,
you know,
like a long time ago,
there was no chance I would be able to sit down with you and do a conversation.
You would just be some,
you know,
author whose books I admired.
But now because of this crazy thing is podcast here we are sitting down,
Graham Hancock has joined us and if you don't know who Graham Hancock is,
Graham Hancock is probably,
uh,
the one guy who's influenced my view of history more than anybody ever.
It's from this book,
fingerprints of the Gods and fingerprints of the gods is a,
what is it sold like 5 million copies or something crazy like
forgot about that.
Yeah.
It's an amazing book that basically challenges our view of history.
And,
um,
you have spent an enormous chunk of your life uncovering all these different
structures and all these different monuments and all these different things that
you attribute to a lost era of humanity.
And I want to,
my favorite terms that you use is that we're a species with hypnosis,
or excuse me,
with Amnesia.
With Amnesia.
Yeah.
And that please tell me where,
how did all this get cracking?
How did this get started for you?
Wow.
Well,
it's,
everything that's happened in my life has happened kind of by a series of
accidents.
I,
I never,
I never planned out anything except I kind of,
I kind of knew when I was young that I had one gift,
which was,
uh,
some ability to write.
And the other thing that bugged me was,
it's when all through my childhood,
I always felt I was on the edge of things,
not in the middle of things.
Other people were in the middle.
I was on the edge.
I just always felt that way.
And,
uh,
when I got through university,
I kind of drifted towards,
towards writing current affairs,
journalism.
Um,
and it was while following journalistic stories.
I,
my last journalistic role was as the east African correspondent for the
economist.
Quite a,
quite a serious newspaper.
And I was based in Nairobi in Kenya and I was covering wars and famines and
politics and all of that stuff.
And on my beat was Ethiopia.
And I used to go to Ethiopia quite regularly.
It was in the news a lot.
And,
uh,
on one journey to Ethiopia,
I flew into a city that the time was in the middle of a war zone in a DC three
that kind of dive down out of the sky to avoid the machine gun nests in the
surrounding hills and landed in the airport.
And this was an ancient city called [inaudible].
And it had,
um,
incredible history.
It had obelisks.
It had a polished,
supposedly of the Queen of Sheba had an ancient cathedral,
the most ancient Christian cathedral in Africa,
dating back to the 300 after Christ.
And in the grounds of that cathedral in a chapel outside the chapel.
I meet a monk and,
uh,
he tells me in the conversation,
we have the,
he's got the Ark of the Covenant in that Chapel.
This was,
I had heard that the Ark of the covenant was important to Ethiopia,
but now I'm sitting in front of a monk with cataracts in his eyes and he's
telling me behind him in that chapel,
but I can't go,
there is the Ark of the covenant.
And I said,
you know,
can I go,
can I,
can I see it?
And he said,
no,
no.
Nobody can see it.
Even the former emperors were never allowed to see the ark of the covenant.
You know,
the Raiders of the lost ark movie had come out only like a couple of years
before this.
This was in the early eighties.
And,
um,
so I left that place impressed by the,
this man,
but not really believing it.
And then I started to look into it and I discovered that actually Ethiopia is
the only country in the world which has a living veneration,
almost worship of the Ark of the covenant.
A Ethiopia has ancient Christianity,
but it also has ancient Judaism.
There's a Jewish community in Ethiopia called the fellowship.
They call themselves the better Israel.
How did they get there?
They practice a very ancient form of Judaism.
They don't have rabbis,
they have priests.
They perform sacrifice,
other Judaic people's do not.
Um,
it's like an old testament world frozen in the highlands of Ethiopia.
So I started to get interesting,
this is,
this is weird and this is exciting and what can I find out about this?
Then I went to the academics and they said,
ah,
it's all rubbish.
Those ETL bins,
they just made it up to make themselves look big.
Okay,
but then why is it the case that in every single church in Ethiopia,
more than 20,000 churches,
there's a replica of the Ark of the Covenant in the Holy of holies.
What does it look like?
Well,
mostly it's a box and sometimes actually they,
they reduced the replica to simply two tablets,
which are supposed to represent the tablets of stone inside the Ark of the
covenant.
But the Ark of the covenant is not a Christian object.
It's a pretty Christian object.
What's it doing in all these churches are,
why is,
where does this all come from?
Why do we have the black Jews of Ethiopia practicing?
They're very ancient form of Judaism.
So I really started to dig and I kind of as a first time I realized that,
uh,
you don't want to listen to academics all the time.
Professor x and doctor y may be very,
very impressive people with their credentials,
but they have prejudices.
They have a fixed view of the past,
which they're going to stick to come what may,
and as I started to investigate this,
this is what drew me out of current affairs and into ancient mysteries.
I,
I found that here was a real investigation,
a story that had never been told,
uh,
could this remote country in the Horn of Africa,
really half the Ark of the covenant.
And if so,
how could it have got there?
And I spent several years of my life trying to
answer those questions.
And by that time,
by the time I got to the end of that investigation that I had left current
affairs behind and hooked,
I was hooked on the past.
What did you ever wonder if you were going crazy?
Like here I am really investigating of some people in Ethiopia actually have
some crazy thing from a book.
No,
it makes no sense and really thought it was real.
I,
it wasn't that I thought it was real.
I was,
I was either thought no,
I didn't think that I was impressed by the Ethiopians themselves.
And I was impressed by the purity of their belief and the passion with which
they held it.
And the fact that here,
after thousands of years,
this object disappeared from the Bible,
um,
at the time,
well roundabout 650 years before Christ,
it's not mentioned again in the Bible.
After that,
it vanishes.
Um,
and,
and yet here is,
it's worship in,
in 20th century.
Ethiopia today is,
how do we explain this?
And it was.
And as I dug deeper,
I began to realize that,
uh,
actually there was a real possibility they did have the Ark of the covenant and
that it is connected to the mystery of the Ethiopian Jews.
Um,
and,
and that the story they themselves tell about it,
which connects it.
It's a drawer,
very romantic and lovely story.
They say in brief that the Queen of Sheba,
famous queen of Sheba was an Ethiopian queen and that she,
when she traveled to Jerusalem to meet Solomon,
which is described in the Bible,
big,
big episode in the Bible.
Um,
she didn't only exchange wisdom with him,
she also exchanged bodily fluids and she became pregnant,
uh,
with King Solomon son,
who was to be called Menelik,
which,
which actually means the son of the wise man and a pregnant.
She left Jerusalem,
returned to Ethiopia,
gave birth to her son,
Menelik there at the age of 20 or 21,
he wanted to visit his famous father in Jerusalem.
He traveled north,
went to Jerusalem,
spent a year there,
and at the end of the year contrived to steal the Ark of the covenant from
Jerusalem and take it off to Ethiopia.
And there it's been ever since.
That's the Ethiopian story,
I believe behind that legend,
there's a true history of how it really got there.
And that's what I,
that's in the end,
what I ended up writing my first book of historical mysteries above,
which was the sign of the seal
and wasn't the speculation about the Ark of the covenant,
that it was some sort of a technological device that was actually radioactive.
Yes,
yes.
I got into that speculation myself at some length because as I started to
investigate this subject,
not only was the Ethiopian side of it fascinating and mysterious,
but the object itself is quite extraordinary.
I mean,
it dominates the Bible at the beginning of the story from the time they're in
Sinai,
the exodus there,
there's a tremendous role for the Ark of the Covenant and they follow it through
the Wilderness and it's marched around the city of Jericho.
It knocks down the walls of Jericho.
Um,
it's hugely important.
The temple of Solomon is built with only one function and that's to serve,
and this is a quote as an house of rest for the Ark of the covenant of the Lord.
That's the only reason that the temple of Solomon is built is like at a certain
point,
it's got to be placed out of the public view.
It's always a dangerous object as they're carrying it.
It strikes people dead.
If somebody touches it by chance.
Boulder fire comes out of it.
Actually.
I mean,
Spielberg and the Indiana Jones movie,
the way they portrayed the arc was spot on.
How it's described in the old testament as an absolutely devastating deadly
instrument.
So it's the,
the Israelites use it,
didn't battle it.
There's a accounts of it flying into the air,
rushing towards the enemies of Israel,
emitting a moaning sound.
They all fall down dead.
Then there's a,
a later account,
whether the Philistines capture the Ark of the covenant,
they take it off to the city of Ashdod.
Then they make the huge mistake of opening it and they treated like a tourist
object.
People walk by,
the Bible says 50,000 died.
And how did they die?
Cancerous tumors.
That's what's,
that's what's actually described in the,
in the Bible.
So the covenant is supposed to contain within it once laughed at the 10 can
attempt mum.
That's correct.
That's what's supposed to be inside of it.
And also isn't there a written upon by the finger of God himself,
if you,
if you take the old testament and that's,
and that and that.
They're the kind of power source of the Ark of the covenant.
Now,
what that power is,
uh,
I did get into some speculation on this.
It seems obvious to me that that at one level the Ark of the covenant is an out
of place technology.
It's a,
it's a strange technology which is,
which is,
um,
which is presented itself in a surprising context where you don't expect to find
it.
And there it is.
So I started to look into the background of this.
Where did this come from?
And where it comes from is Egypt.
Moses is intimately connected with the Ark of the covenant.
Moses is raised in the household of the Pharaoh in Egypt.
He's groomed to be a future farrow,
uh,
and then the falling outcomes and he leaves with the children of Israel and
builds the Ark of the covenant in the site in the Sinai.
Uh,
now,
if he was raised and groomed as a future pharaoh than he would have been a
magician,
he would have been versed in the high magic of ancient Egypt.
And those guys could do virtually anything they set their minds to.
I mean,
anybody who can build the Great Pyramid of Egypt,
if it was built when we're told him was built,
um,
it's an extraordinary,
yeah.
Even if it was before then,
whenever people don't understand what you're talking about here,
you,
your,
your premise or a big part of it is that there is somewhere around,
what is it,
10,000 years ago,
somewhere around then,
towards the end of the last ice age,
humanity was probably mostly wiped out or wiped out in a big way.
And we had to rebuild from there.
And we,
and I believe that we lost,
uh,
a civilization at that time,
the entire civilization,
which is not being recorded by history,
uh,
and that it underwater
with the rising sea levels.
And what led me to this,
well,
the reason I became interested in pursuing that line of inquiry was the Ark of
the covenant because it seemed to me,
it seemed to me like a piece of technology that was out of its place in history,
in the way that it was described.
I'm not wishing to put down the spiritual aspects because they are there.
Uh,
but there were definite technological aspects to this device.
And then I had to ask myself,
well,
where could that knowledge have come from?
And through Egypt,
we then start to find that Egypt itself looks back to an older time.
The ancient Egyptians didn't regard themselves as the beginning of their story.
They regarded themselves as quite a late point in their story.
And they look back to the time of the gods,
which they called Zep Tepi the first time when there was a golden age and they
speak and there are texts,
the Ed for building texts,
which speak of the guards living on an island,
a gigantic flood coming.
Most of the gods are killed.
Odd thing to happen to gods.
And then they,
uh,
come and settle in Egypt.
The survivors come and settle in Egypt.
And
so Egypt is the product of an even far earlier civilization,
but,
but the history of Egypt goes back way,
way further than people think it does.
That's my view.
I support that view.
And I was astonished when you had Robert Schoch in John Anthony West when they
brought their findings about the erosion on the,
the,
the temple of the Sphinx.
Yes.
They brought these findings to these academics and just the,
the tone of their voice,
the way they were approaching the information,
the mocking attitude that they had of it.
Well,
where is this civilization?
You speak up because they're talking about a civilization that was possibly,
what,
10,000 BC or something like that running around.
I would put the finger right about 10,500 BC when people,
if you don't know the,
the,
the story behind it.
There's water erosion on the edge of the,
uh,
the,
the temple of the Sphinx has done that could only be attributed to thousands of
years of rainfall.
That's the last time there was rainfall in the Nile Valley was breakthrough
work that John Anthony West and Robert Schoch did that.
The initial observation,
um,
w came through John,
who is,
uh,
an at astonishingly knowledgeable man about ancient Egypt.
He's not a official Egyptologist,
but he spent his whole life working in ancient Egypt.
And through his research and his background,
he came to,
he came to realize that the erosion patterns on the Sphinx are really odd.
And he then went to shock,
uh,
Robert Schoch at the University of Boston who is a geologist and an open minded
one.
And he said,
would you come to Egypt with me and give me your geological opinion on this
monument?
So shock went there and it was immediately clear to him that this monument had
been subjected to thousands of years of heavy rainfall at some point in its
history.
And that's where the mystery begins because the study of ancient climates is
quite well advanced.
And we know that 5,000 years ago,
four and a half thousand years ago when the Sphinx is supposed to have been
built,
Egypt was as Moen dry as it is today,
and you have to go back some thousands of years before that at two,
about 9,000 years ago to get the very heavy rainfall that would have caused the
erosion of those things.
But that only means that the Sphinx was standing there 9,000 years ago to be
rained on.
Uh,
it may be much older than that.
A shock is cautious and he will not,
he will not push the date back beyond what the hard evidence suggests he's
willing to is what he does,
except that the Sphinx may well have stood there,
uh,
before the heavy rains began.
But how long before is a,
is a matter that he cannot be certain on.
And that's where,
uh,
Robert Boulevard and I were able to take the matter on a little further with the
astronomy of the Giza plateau.
And you find there's this just this stunning thing that happens in the sky.
I mean,
this is one of,
one of the great things.
I have some problems with technology,
but I have to say one of the great things about computer technology is the way
that it can speed up access to information in an incredibly efficient way.
And there are computer programs now,
which we'll show you exactly how the stars were positioned at any time in the
last 30,000 years over.
At any point on the earth's surface,
you can literally wind back the ancient skies and see them.
And this guy's do change because the earth is the viewing platform from which we
observe the stars.
There's a wobble on the axis of the earth course.
That's right.
And the wobble takes 20 to 26,000 years to complete a cycle.
So it's a cyclical process.
Eventually the stars will all return to starting point and begin the cycle
again.
And because of that,
we can say that the Sphinx was gazing at his own celestial counterpart.
The constellation of Leo at dawn on the Spring Equinox in 10,000 BC,
while 90 degrees away due south Orion was lying on the Meridian in exactly the
pattern of the pyramids on the ground.
Who doesn't?
John Anthony West go even deeper.
He believes it's like 30,000 BC.
John John thinks it might be pushed back another processional cycle.
You see the,
we,
we take it back to two 12 and a half thousand years ago.
Uh,
but you would have the same alignments another 26,000 years earlier.
So 38,000 years ago you would have the same alignments as you had 12 and a half
thousand years.
Doesn't he base it on actual hieroglyphs to depict the images of the Pharaohs
and absolutely.
Right.
There's the,
and again,
this is the area where the Egyptologists,
the academic Egyptologists are incredibly annoying because they will not listen
to what the ancient Egyptians themselves had to say.
It's as though they,
the academics know more about ancient Egyptian history than the ancient
Egyptians did themselves.
And the ancient Egyptians were really very clear.
They pushed their history back,
well plus 30,000 years defensive.
Why don't that,
why,
why won't they buy?
Why are they so again,
I wondered that myself.
Uh,
when I first got into this,
I initially couldn't understand it,
but I think,
I think it's a problem with science in general.
Uh,
I think that,
uh,
was it a late discovery?
Did they have an established timeline?
They race government.
There's the timeline.
The timeline was set literally in stone,
uh,
over the last sort of last 50,
50 years of the 20th century.
I mean really Biden,
by the beginning of the 20th century,
a timeline had been worked out and by the 1950s,
it was very much set.
So they are just not willing to consider any previous day that would anything.
That was the whole timeline out.
And because they've been teaching it for so long,
they're reluctant to open up to new ideas.
I would say so.
But also,
but also they themselves,
I'm not suggesting any dishonesty on their part.
They themselves absolutely believe their version of the past
and in all fairness,
you know Robert Shocks,
depiction of the erosion,
there have been dissenters and I've read some,
some different people's pavers,
but they seem very logical and I looked at it myself,
I know what water erosion looks like.
Obviously I'm not a geologist,
but when I look at it and you say that that's wind and sand and then they showed
extreme examples of wind in Santa Rosa,
it's,
well it doesn't look the same.
There's,
it looks like there's crevices.
It's been created by water.
It's really obvious.
It really does.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and then there's so much else that adds to that.
I mean there's,
this thinks is not alone there.
There are other,
whether it's structures out there on the Giza plateau,
all of them,
the ones under deep and they find ones that are underground that are these old
style construction ones that were built much like this.
The temple,
the Sphinx,
but not like the later stuff.
Then it looks like two different areas of construction
does it looks like two phases of construction.
One very ancient,
one more recent,
and they've got muddled up in the academics mind
watching doctor shock.
Try to talk to the Egyptologists about that was,
it was a fascinating thing because the guy got super defensive and he was like,
where,
where is this civilization you're speaking of this 10,000 Polo?
It was like this,
Marx was Marc Alania who's an egyptologist at the Oriental Institute in Chicago
and one of the lead West archeologists working in Giza,
you know,
and his remark,
which we quite often was,
you know,
um,
show me the pot shirt where whereas the pot shirt from this,
from this last civilization,
well,
the argument was at that time that the Sphinx cannot possibly be of that age
because there's nothing else in the world of that age.
How could it just be this one unique thing,
which is 12 and a half thousand years old or maybe older,
uh,
this amazing the monument.
How can that be alone?
Then she'll show me the pictures of the rest of that civilization.
Well,
some years later,
those poachers have started to turn up and they've turned up in Turkey,
uh,
in the form of a gold back.
Tapi a gigantic megalithic circle,
uh,
which dates back to precisely 12,000 years ago
and even has carvings of animals that don't exist anywhere near Turkey on the,
on this thing.
And they're trying to attribute it to hunter gatherers,
which is hilarious.
Yeah,
it was really hilarious.
Um,
the,
these,
these were people who had an organized and systematic a civilization,
and it was somehow or another intentionally covered up.
Alright.
They buried it,
buried these gigantic,
like 12 foot tall,
beautiful stone carvings were like lizards on them and stuff.
By the way,
that the ancient Egyptians themselves decommissioned some of their temples when
they knew their system was going down.
They knew it was going down.
The Romans were the end of it for Egypt.
The Egyptians thrived through the Greek period.
When the Greeks arrived in Egypt.
What happened was the Egyptians colonize the Greek mind and the Greeks became
Egyptians.
But when the Romans took over,
it was a different story.
That's my people.
They fat everywhere.
Still.
We're still,
yeah.
When the Romans,
uh,
made this alliance with Christianity and the,
the,
the Christian Church pulled on the Jackboot of Rome.
It was Christians who really wanted to take Egypt apart.
They wanted to destroy everything and the Egyptian priests themselves rather
than let their temples fall into their hands in that way,
they went around and destroyed certain things in the temples and they did so
quite,
quite deliberately to,
to remove that power from the others who are going to come and take it in.
[inaudible]
I've only been to a couple places.
I've been to a Chichi needs.
Uh,
I've never been to Egypt,
but I've been to a,
at the,
um,
one of the Museum of Fine Arts in Boston had an Egyptian exhibit.
They had all this amazing old shit and the is so hard to wrap your head or even
the established timeline of 2,500 BC when you're looking at these structures,
it's so hard to wrap your head around.
Like when you're looking at a beautiful gold and covered sarcophagus that you
know,
had King Tut and side of it.
It's like,
what,
what was that like?
You know what kind of a weird alternative way to live that these guys figure out
where they lose ends of years ago,
figured out how to build these almost perfect geometric structures of 2 million,
300,000 stones where if you fuck up just a little bit here or there,
by the time you get to the top it's done.
And they're like,
well,
they did screw up a few of them.
There's a few of them.
The lopsided.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But they got them right to who knows who the hell was doing a screw up.
Ones that could have been imitated
ones were done later.
Bye.
By by,
um,
the copiers skills based basically is,
that's the mystery of Egypt is that that a,
and John West makes this point,
but that a,
it's perfect at the beginning and it slowly declines.
This is not what we expect.
We expect to see civilizations slowly rise.
We don't expect to see them perfect,
fully formed at the beginning and then take 3000 years to end.
Right.
Well,
even when you pushed back the established timeline and you know,
we,
we can't even wrap our head around a thousand years.
I mean,
a thousand years is very difficult to wrap your head around.
Why do you think it's so difficult for them to embrace the pretty obvious
possibility that things get wiped out?
I mean,
there's craters all over the moon.
We know there's all sorts of spots all over,
you know,
you'll go drive by the giant crater in Nevada.
It's a mile wide
boom,
something hits,
everybody gets fucked.
That easily could have happened over and over again throughout history.
And just that seems to me to be way more likely than we made it all the way from
caveman to here without a hiccup,
with a single hiccup.
That's crazy.
And this leads,
you know,
this,
this leads to certainly led me to conclude that that um,
academic history,
um,
is part of,
uh,
this sounds a bit paranoid,
but part of an overall system of kind of mind control that that operates.
There are certain things that we're allowed to think and certain parameters that
we are allowed to think within in our society.
And,
and when it comes to the past,
those parameters are set by academics and they'd get so territorial and so
defensive when you tried to break out of that,
uh,
and,
and suggest other policy.
I thought naively when I got into this at first that,
uh,
those who were specialists in this field would welcome some new ideas.
Um,
they might throw them out in the end,
but they would want to see whether there was any merit to the ideas.
And so initially I was really shocked that the attitude is,
oh,
this idea doesn't agree with us.
We are going to destroy this idea in any way we can add.
Not only that we're going to destroy the individuals associated with this idea.
We will attack the man and the idea
ad hominem attack.
Exactly,
exactly.
And a very dirty tricks kind of way.
It's only later
Toronto actually,
that I came to realize that academics all treat each other this way as well.
They're all there.
They're all very Terrett,
very territorial.
They are all ego driven.
They have their power base in a particular view and they defend that view to
the,
to the
death.
Now when you say the doctor shock is a very conservative,
you're not joking around about that.
And I always wonder when I hear some of the things that he says about other
ancient structures,
I always wonder,
wow,
I wonder if he took too much heat from the Sphinx.
And now he like backs off on stuff.
He's very Bosnian pyramid and even the Japanese structure,
did you say went there?
I went there with shock and he's crazy and shock would not,
that's crazy.
He shoved.
Wouldn't a shock,
a shock
would not accept that it was a manmade structure bed.
But I have to say that at that point,
um,
you want a Goonie is a very difficult dive.
It's a very difficult time.
The seas are wild.
There's a huge current flows right in front of the monument and you have to be
an accomplished diver to do any work.
Uh,
shock was on his second open water dive at this point and a on those initial
dives that we did on,
on a Goonie,
um,
he was largely fighting for his life.
Do
you guys have balls?
I love it.
It's very,
you know,
but my wife's Santo,
who,
who's a photographer and I sound right here with us,
have done,
yeah,
man.
Um,
uh,
more than 200 plus dives on the Yana Goonie monument.
We went through the process of learning to dive and really getting the skills to
be able to handle that kind of current,
which is literally gonna rip your mask off your face and take your regulator out
of your mouth.
Um,
it's like swimming in a river against the current actually.
So what I would say is that I think shock was a little premature with that
conclusion and I think,
uh,
he,
he's,
I have huge respect for rubbish shock and I have huge respect for his openness
of mind at his geological acumen,
but there's not enough time was spent on the monument to reach that decision.
And it's not just one monument.
It's a whole complex of monuments.
And further north settles it for me off a Aki nowhere,
which is about four or 500 miles north of Yana Goonie.
There is a majestic stone circle,
110 feet beneath the water,
which again,
something I've dived on extensively,
which shock has not seen a,
which is there's just no way on earth that that monument could have been their
photos of this online.
Yes,
we do.
We have photos on my website I look for,
um,
okay.
You go on to www grab,
I'm sure if I just Google it and go to Graham hancock.com okay.
And then go to gallery
and then go to underwater.
We have underwater on the gallery.
Okay.
Under water.
Yes.
And in the underwater section you're going to see a stone circle from where
there with uh,
with somebody above it holding a video camera.
That's me holding the video camera.
Yeah.
And down on the,
down below you is a stone circle and there's probably some more shots of it.
I'm going to just come around and see what you're looking at there.
I was looking at this right here.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
That's the stone circle.
This is the central upright and these are the surrounding uprights.
Yeah.
That's somebody made that get out of this thing.
This thing is 12 feet high.
Wow.
And it's 110 feet beneath the seat.
Yeah.
So cool.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That's amazing.
It's the most extraordinary thing.
Um,
and 110 feet beneath the sea tells us that it was made at least 13,000 years ago
because that's the last time that 110 foot level was above sea level.
Well that makes sense with Robert Schoch about these ruins,
the Japanese ruins,
cause there's one of them that really freaked me out.
I watched a documentary on it where they showed this,
these two monolith.
We talked earlier,
I described them as pizza boxes with the giant stone pizza boxes.
There were so perfectly cut in laying right next to each other.
I would just think you would look at that and you'd have to throw everything
else away.
You look at that and you're like,
that's not a natural phenomenon.
Somebody,
there's right angles everywhere that sends off.
Well it does.
I mean the beauty and the perfection of the thing is,
is is part of it,
but,
but part of it,
which needs to be needs to be taken into account.
I can understand why some geologists feel that it must be natural.
And this is this.
This is the reason that the stone is a sedimentary stone is laid down in layers
and some of the layers are soft and some of them are hard.
And their argument is that the sea battering against these less selectively
remove the soft layers and left the hard layers producing this step defect.
The problem with that is that if that happened,
then you would expect to see the very large amount of rubble,
which was created by removing all these layers.
You'd expect to see it lying in a disorganized mass down at the bottom of the
monument.
Uh,
which the tea,
the from top to bottom,
the monuments about 70 feet high.
So 70 feet down and all of it's under water because the,
that you,
it's the bottom is about 110 feet below the sea.
So you would expect to find that rubble lying at the base of the monument.
Actually what you do find is a beautiful path cutout of solid rock at the base
of the monument and all the rubble cleared to the side pushed away,
uh,
forming a bank,
which is no way on earth that could have been done by nature.
It had to be done by man.
That's what peer,
that's what people do.
They clear away,
rubble,
tidy it up and leave a nice looking site.
And that's what,
that's what is,
that's what is there.
So it's little details like that plus the,
the fact that there isn't just one monument,
there's actually about five,
uh,
along a good four miles of the coast,
makes it impossible for me to accept that it's a natural phenomenon.
And I guess the question comes up when you,
when you talk about ancient monuments are ancient civilizations for 14,000 plus
years ago,
how much really would be left?
It's a long time.
The sole long we are,
we are for it.
To put it in perspective.
The House that we're in and 14,000 years will absolutely not be here.
Now.
If we leave,
it's going to be completely gone.
There'll be almost no evidence.
The earth will devour these computers.
It will devour the leather and the table and the chairs to rueful cave in and
we'll all go into dirt,
dirt.
We'll fill it over.
Lava will come.
Earthquakes,
we'll shift things.
It'd be gone.
Will be forgotten,
forgotten,
forgotten.
It would be very,
very easy for that to happen.
Then consider the effect of ice.
Uh,
consider it.
Consider the fact that,
uh,
during the last ice age,
North America and northern Europe were covered with these gigantic ice caps.
There.
You're talking ice,
which is two to three miles deep.
Your website's getting crushed right now.
Generally get on your website.
All these,
sorry about that.
Interrupt your getting smashed.
So could use.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people on that sucker.
Glad to hear it.
Um,
you know,
so,
so I'm sorry,
I lost my thread.
I'm so sorry.
We're talking about North America.
So the ice forms on the continental land mass of the u s end of Europe,
it builds up to a depth of two miles and it's in motion.
Consider what's happening to anything underneath that under two miles of ice.
It's being ground to a powder to a fine powder.
It's like,
uh,
it's like just wiping out,
literally wiping out the park.
So that's why it was such a big deal to find that ice man because he had fallen
into a crevice and sort of the glacier had passed over him and never touched
him.
Wait,
what ice man,
what's this guy?
Let's
see.
In,
in Italy,
he's about five and a half thousand years old and he fell into a glazier in the
obs and he came out of it again in the late 20th century.
Uh,
and uh,
there's an interesting story actually.
It's fascinating.
It looks like he was murdered.
Uh,
they found an Arrow embedded in his body.
He and he was looked like he'd been ambushed and shot up there
and he died there and frozen was covered with snow immediately and then he was
preserved than some hikers found his body.
It's amazing story,
man.
But what's incredible is that if this,
if Graham's view of history is true,
then this guy 5,000 years ago was really like some dude who survived some
horrible cataclysmic event,
you know,
the,
the civilization moved for people,
relearn things,
relearned hunting,
re-learned,
you know,
making skins and turning them into fabric or turning them into clothes.
What's your,
what,
what's your theory of where it all started?
Where,
where did we come from?
Why,
where did humans originate?
Okay.
Well,
I think that,
um,
I'm,
I'm not against the,
uh,
academic reconstruction of the human family tree.
I think they've done some,
I think they've done some quite good work.
So,
uh,
tell us your question.
I'll have to go back to,
uh,
go back quite far to the last common ancestor with the chimpanzee,
which is about 6 million years ago.
And then from then,
um,
you get a gradual emergence of a creature who begins to look more and more
human.
And by two and a half million years ago,
that creature is making stone tools.
The first sign of real intelligent activity,
I'm going to turn the air conditioning,
but the,
but the stone tools,
um,
are very limited and once the creature has invented them,
it doesn't change for the next million years.
The stone tools stay exactly the same.
So we know that they're passing down cultural information and we also know that
they're extremely rigid in their thought patterns and they're stuck in that.
Then a new type of stone tool is introduced and that one sticks for another
million years as well.
Um,
and during this time,
our ancestors of looking more and more like us.
And finally,
uh,
the earliest surviving fully anatomically modern human skeleton comes from
Ethiopia.
As a matter of fact,
and it's 195,000 years old as just short of 200,000 years old.
Before that,
we,
the,
the creatures were closely related to us,
but they didn't look quite like us.
And their brains were not quite like ours,
but by 195,000 years ago,
anatomically modern humans have evolved,
but their behavior has not evolved.
Their behavior is stuck,
uh,
in,
in that archaic period.
And they're still using the same limited,
unimaginative stone tools that were being used a million years before.
And then it's a really extraordinary thing happens and it's within the last
50,000 years,
is that you just get this incredible surge forward in,
in human behavior.
Uh,
the dawn of spiritual beliefs,
the,
they're very,
very clear because they started burying food and water with the debt that
anybody who does that,
they definitely believed that some aspect of the individual continues after
death and they created the great cave art,
the amazing,
amazing painting,
stunning works of art.
All of the symbolic behavior seem to just switch on kind of overnight somewhere
after 50,000 years ago.
And I,
so I would,
I would start the clock about there where,
where,
where suddenly you've got these incredibly intelligent,
artistic,
creative creatures on the planet who are asked and they are doing this stuff.
And I,
and I believe that some of them,
uh,
stayed in the hunter gatherer mode all the way through,
all the way through history.
Uh,
the,
and,
and those were the,
the cave artists and they have what's called the Upper Paleolithic.
And I think some of them moved in another direction and formed a civilization.
And just as today on,
in,
in our 21st century world,
uh,
we have highly advanced technological civilizations coexisting with hunter
gatherers.
You do still have traditional hunter gatherers in the Amazon,
in Botswana,
for example.
Uh,
I believe it was the same in the world then.
and I think that the,
the what I think of as the lost civilization was largely Ameritime civilization,
living along coastlines,
living on the best land during the ice age,
cause inland.
It was horrid.
It was cold.
That was the ice meant.
There was no rain.
Right,
right.
It's totally desert.
Um,
very,
very difficult to live.
But on the coasts,
things were much better.
And it was precisely the coasts that we're inundated when mysteriously and
suddenly the ice age ended and all that ice started to melt down and went back
into the ocean and the sea levels rose.
And you think that,
I mean,
I read,
I've read all your books.
I read a supernatural as well,
just one of my more favorite or more,
uh,
what I found more fascinating because if you really stepped down on some serious
limbs on that one,
man did.
Yeah.
I mean,
you come from the journey from being a journalist who was covering this thing in
Ethiopia to supernatural,
which insinuates that humanity has probably learned a good deal of what we are
and what we've become because of psychedelic drugs.
I believe that's absolutely the case.
And,
and I think that,
uh,
with the current a demonization of psychedelic drugs in our society,
it's a huge mistake.
How much resistance have you felt from that book?
Well,
I've had an enormous amount of resistance to it.
Um,
because,
uh,
we have had,
um,
a mind programming exercise called the war on drugs for the last 40 years,
which has been designed to create an internal enemy in our societies and
convince people that there are these evil,
wicked groups who are doing these terrible sinful things,
smoking these drugs and doing,
doing this and that.
And it's very dark image has been created around it and people get very upset
irrationally about this,
uh,
about this whole issue.
And actually what's been forgotten in,
uh,
in all of this and from,
for me,
it's become,
I regard it as an extremely important issue,
uh,
is that when the state,
um,
sends us to prison for essentially exploring our own,
uh,
this is a grotesque abuse of human rights.
It's a,
it's a fundamental wrong.
If I as an adult have not sovereign over my own consciousness,
then I'm absolutely not sovereign over anything.
I can't claim any kind of freedom at all.
And,
and,
and what has happened over the last 40 or 50 years under the disguise of the war
on drugs is that that we have been persuaded to hand over the keys of our
consciousness to the state,
the most precious,
the most intimate,
the most sapient part of ourselves.
The state now has the keys and furthermore,
they've persuaded us that that's in our interests.
This is a very dangerous situation.
Have you ever,
there was a,
an article that was recently published a about people and creativity and that,
you know,
everyone says they love creative ideas,
but the truth is amongst non creative people,
creative ideas,
make them confrontational,
makes them upset and make them defensive.
When when you start talking about experiences like psychedelic experiences,
one of the things that always freaks me out is the people's inability to even
consider that there's a difference between a psychedelic experience on drugs and
a drug that's going to ruin your life.
They're not even interested in considering that possibility.
There's two different,
it's like the same thing.
It's like someone resisting
definitely.
And that again,
that's the result.
Lesser of this.
Remember that the programming funded with our money,
our taxpayers money.
There has been 40 years of programming,
more than 40 years on this subject to make us all develop a kind of a version of
a fear or hatred,
the horror of of,
of,
of drugs.
And this is,
it's just fundamentally wrong in so in so many ways,
look quite a number of illegal drugs are actually really bad and really
dangerous and they will totally fuck you up in all kinds of,
in all kinds of ways.
But I believe that the sovereignty of the adult over his or her own body and his
or her own mind trumps everything else should.
And we must have the right to make our mistakes.
You know,
we already have laws in our society for punishing bad behavior.
If somebody on drugs goes out and gets in somebody else's face and causes them
trouble,
we already have laws to deal that we don't need new laws that control our
consciousness and rigidly place it in a prison and actually placed us in prison.
So we explored that courtroom.
You just said that we already have laws to keep it from doing bad things.
It's so important.
We don't.
Yeah,
it seems so logical.
It's like so clear.
If you can drink and not do anything bad,
go drink.
Exactly.
If he's going to smoke pot and not doing anything bad to your fellow human,
go smoke pot.
If that's what you want to do.
If that's your adult decision,
that's your choice.
That what does liberty mean if it,
if it doesn't mean that the people in the right get into this ridiculous,
just obey the law.
Why is it such a hard time?
What are you a Druggie?
You new drugs get through this life.
We say this is such an illogical argument cause imagine if we were on an island,
we're the only people on the planet and there was only four of us.
There's only four of us.
One of us wanted to
smoke pot and we said,
no,
we gotta lock this guy and put in a fucking cage.
He's crazy and we decided to use it to that debt.
Then you really see the dicey how silly it is.
Like you,
you would just lock this guy.
But again,
you can't smoke pot.
We made a law against it.
Like what that for is just as ridiculous as 4 million,
400 million or what?
It's just as ridiculous an extraordinary thing.
And,
and you have to consider what it's led to in our society in all kinds of ways.
It's led to the creation of huge armed bureaucracies who have the right to break
into our homes,
smashed down our doors,
humiliate us in every possible way,
ruin our lives with,
with,
with criminal records and all.
Because what we're,
we're,
we're smoking some natural natural herb,
which we,
which,
which affects our own consciousness in some way.
So again,
I say if we get into the faces of others to state may have a role to play and it
does and it already has elaborate rules for dealing with that.
But for the state to have transgressed,
the consciousness of free sovereign adults is a grotesque abuse of human rights
and it doesn't work.
This is the other thing.
If the state could turn around and say,
the war on drugs has worked,
we have reduced the consumption of this,
that it's not true.
They haven't reduced the consumption of any drugs.
The consumption of the El,
all illegal drugs has gone up,
up and up and up and up and up.
Let's take another drug.
Tobacco,
you never got sent to jail for smoking tobacco.
You never got your life for Real Indo your front door broken down.
But some years ago people cottoned on to the notion that tobacco actually maybe
making yes,
pretty unwell.
If we're smoking a lot of tobacco,
uh,
seems to be a connection with lung cancer.
And this was,
uh,
this information was put forward.
Look what's happened with tobacco in the last 20 years.
Millions,
millions and millions of adults all over the world presented with that
information,
have taken a personal sovereign decision to stop smoking cigarettes.
I took that decision when I was 38 years old.
I used to,
I'm 61 now.
I used to smoke 40 cigarettes a day and a,
I was a journalist,
you know,
cigarette hanging out of their mouth type writer.
I was a heavy smoker,
but I took the decision,
I came to the collusion.
This is not good for my body.
You know,
Steven King said that it was a,
as a neurotransmitter and enhancer that he suffered when he stopped smoking.
So many writers,
but when you are right,
why did you smoke so much as a writer?
Uh,
it helps.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
It definitely did.
It definitely did help,
uh,
as as does marijuana.
Um,
but uh,
the fact is that there is,
the point that I want to make is that is that if the state was really interested
in helping us,
this is how the war on drugs is presented,
were concerned about your health.
So we're going to send you to prison.
You know,
we're concerned about the harm this drug is doing to you,
so we're going to send you to prison.
What's more harmful to harm the drug is doing,
are being sent to prison.
It seems to be pretty obvious that the being sent to prison is a much more
harmful thing.
That's a,
that that's being done.
If the state was really concerned about harm,
then the solution is not to criminalize people for taking drugs.
The solution is to present them with very good information,
which they believe part of the problem is that the state has become,
to be regarded as so corrupt that any message emanating from the state about
drugs is not believed anymore completely.
Disbelieved.
Um,
so,
you know,
once again,
we come to this issue of adult sovereignty,
uh,
over over consciousness and our right also to make mistakes with our own body.
If we do that,
that's what we,
I believe we are here on this earth to learn and to grow and to develop.
And we have to have adult responsibility to do that always astonishes me in
America where you have the Republican Party,
which is strongly in favor of individual freedoms,
that is often republicans who are the ones who are most anti-drugs.
Uh,
I feel the drugs is a republican issue.
I think that any true Republican should absolutely champion the right of every
adult individual if they choose to do so,
to explore their own consciousness,
uh,
with any drugs they choose.
There.
There's no real parties anymore.
It's just a mixed mash.
I mean Obama is just as much of a Republican has any republican that's ever been
in office.
I've seen this,
I've seen this happening.
It's weird assimilation.
Yeah,
it is so sure.
Fuck no matter what.
And there's the same purchasing Lee because really our society is being run by a
gigantic,
faceless bureaucracies now and those are much more dangerous than anything else
cause they don't even have a figurehead.
They just continue,
they roll on and they run and they run people's lives.
But the,
the,
the aspect of society where powers that be,
are trying to control people's mental,
um,
uh,
territory.
This is not a new thing has been going on for very,
very long time and newest incarnation.
We had witch burnings where exactly.
Exactly.
I would say that that in our societies today,
drug users play the same role as which is played in Europe in the 16th century.
That's fundamentally what's going on there.
An internal enemy which the society can be mobilized to hate because that's what
the state does.
It makes people hate and fear and suspect other people because then they want to
rely on the state for their defense and their protection.
It's a game.
It's a mind game and it's been going on for a very long time.
And it happens that the current victims are drug users.
Um,
and,
and uh,
you know,
the word that it's interesting to the language itself has been deployed in this
war so that you very rarely find the word drug separated from the word abuse
that you'd ever find,
that the notion of a responsible use of drugs you find only the notion of
abusive drugs.
Um,
and,
and so it's become impossible almost to speak about drugs without incorporating
this,
this notion that there's some abuse is taking place.
Yeah.
And the idea that you can actually benefit from them is an alien thought,
completely alien,
very,
very much hated by,
by our society.
And yet,
you know,
the research is coming through.
We've had the research in the last year with Psilocybin,
uh,
easing
anxiety of terminal cancer patients Mtma with,
um,
with post traumatic stress disorder for fantastically successful as well.
And cancer.
Apparently,
if you've seen that where they're saying no super doses of MDM may,
may,
may treat cancer.
Oh,
joy and love that you'd feel just kills all the bad stuff.
I know.
I mean these,
you know,
these,
um,
I believe that,
well,
Aldous Huxley called the psychedelics gratuitous.
Grace's.
There's something that nature nature just gave us for free kind of grace to,
to allow us to experience a something else.
Um,
and um,
didn't Huxley coined the Term Psychedelic?
He's the one who came up quite possibly.
Yeah,
it was.
Yeah.
Actually.
And um,
I can't remember the other person.
I Ah,
shit man.
Yeah,
I think that they were,
they had different,
they were trying to come up with a word.
They had another word that they were going to use for it,
but it sounded too unsigned
typically.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Yeah,
definitely.
So I can dogs the perfect word.
They nailed it.
Yeah.
What do you subscribe to Mckenna's ideas about the stoned ape theory.
You know,
that theory that human beings may have actually evolved from the lower primates
because of the fact that we ate mushrooms.
Yeah.
Um,
I came to that idea.
Uh,
I,
I'd like to say Terence Mckenna,
one of the great minds,
France,
fascinating.
What a wonderful man,
amazing person.
What a wonderful man and incredible loss that we lost.
Terrence.
He,
he,
he was a remarkable individual and I never met him unfortunately.
Um,
but he,
uh,
I love listening to his voice.
I love his voice.
I have a whole section on my iPod is all turns.
We can have lectures.
Sometimes we go down to Brazil sometimes to drink IOWASCA and,
and sometimes in the late in,
and I'll ask a session as you're beginning to return to this reality.
It's nice to play a bit of music or a little bit of voice and,
and sometimes we play Terence Mckenna and I,
I,
and I just remember one line was about how psychedelics dissolve boundaries.
And he says,
you know,
they'll dissolve boundaries between you and your cat,
even between you and your washing machine.
And I have had wonderful ideas and he,
he very intuitively,
very far,
far ahead of his time,
uh,
grasped the notion that this,
um,
sudden advancement of humanity,
uh,
had to do with psychedelics.
It,
it,
what it did was it broke our rigid behavior patterns that we were stuck in and
unable to change and it opened us up to new possibilities.
And you'll see this remarkable event taking place after 50,000 years ago,
definitely to do with psychedelics.
Now,
you know,
since that time,
there's a parallel track,
which is the academic work on cave art and Psychedelics,
which is professor David Lewis Williams of the University of Witwatersrand in
South Africa.
And he has absolutely taken it beyond intuition and totally proved without any
doubt whatsoever that all of the cave art was inspired by visionary experiences
on psychedelics.
There's just no doubt about that.
All prove that you prove it.
By the nature of the
art itself,
it contains,
it's rich with what are called entoptic phenomenon.
Certain patterns,
zigzags grids,
um,
hexagons,
uh,
honeycomb patterns into nested curved lines.
The caves are covered in all of these go around too.
You know,
the Rock Canyons in Utah,
you'll see the same thing.
Rock art all over the world is really,
is influenced by visionary experiences.
And then classically,
the absolute defining characteristic is the appearance of beings or entities in
the art.
And those entities are typically half human and half animal.
They are,
it's called a 30 anthrop for us from the Greek theory on which means wild beast
and anthropos which means man.
Um,
and this is one of the definitive uh,
aspects of deep visionary experience is encountering a entities who communicate
with you and who are often often encountered in this half man,
half human forms.
So it's interesting that work done in the 1960s with,
for example,
masculine.
Um,
they found that the volunteers were drawing the stuff they saw and one of the
volunteers drew a man in a business suit with the head of a Fox.
Wow.
That was an entity that had come and spoken to him in the,
in the translate steak,
no different from the man with the head of a lion and the body of a human being
that you find in Holland stage startle cave in Germany from 32,000 years ago.
So what do you think is going on there?
Do you think that you're dealing with entities that don't really have a form
that we can understand so they present themselves and some cartoonish
combination of things that we're really aware of?
Yeah.
Uh,
I think that,
I think,
and I'm going out on a limb here,
but I think that we're dealing,
I don't believe consciousness is generated by the brain.
I,
I believe the brain is more of a receiver of consciousness.
I think that's really important distinction.
Um,
the mainstream model of consciousness that we have in our society today
definitely sees it as produced by the brain.
The same way a factory makes cars.
So,
so if you smash up the factory,
uh,
the car stopped being made,
the Ergo,
if you,
if the person dies,
the brain dies.
Consciousness is just blinks out,
gone,
finished.
That's the mainstream view.
But the view,
the other view that the brain is a transceiver or receiver of consciousness that
is manifesting,
it's the junction box that's manifesting consciousness on the physical realm.
Uh,
that raises whole different possibilities.
Then when you destroy the receiver,
the signal is still there just as if you destroy a TV set,
the TV signal is still there.
Um,
and,
uh,
you get,
you get into all kinds of possibilities from that.
So the suggestion that I derive from that is that consciousness is fundamentally
nonphysical,
but that for certain reasons,
and they may be very deep and very mysterious,
consciousness has created realms in which it is possible to manifest physically
because in a physical realm,
you all kinds of consequences to your actions that you would not have in a
nonphysical state.
A physical realm may be a very useful place to spend time if you're an ancient
soul who wishes to learn and grow and develop further.
Uh,
and that's,
that's how I've come to see it.
I think we're,
I think we,
and that's how all ancient spiritual traditions see that we,
that we incarnate in these bodies in order to have the experience of life on
earth,
but we don't die when we die,
when these bodies died.
These bodies are like a suit of clothes that we're wearing for this incarnation.
I've always subscribed to the idea that creativity,
when I'm at my best and most creative and when I'm performing doing standup
comedy at my best and most creative,
I feel much more like a passenger than I do a driver.
Yes.
I feel like when I'm writing,
when I write my best stuff,
I have no idea where it's coming from.
I'm not even really there apps,
I'm just moving my fingers and it's coming to me and it's not even me doing it.
And it sounds ridiculous and you could say that well,
it's because really the ego gets in the way of creativity because you're always
worrying about yourself.
And if you could just put the ego aside,
then your mind can work better.
And I see that argument,
but I don't really,
it feels like it comes to me in these great bursts of,
of ideas that I never considered before and I'm like,
well wait,
where's that?
Is that,
it may be.
That's really something that I'm figuring out a way to down from tune in.
Yeah,
you're cheating.
You're shooting into it and you're becoming a channel four for the material,
for your own material,
your,
your consciousness is,
is running the show,
but your consciousness is not limited to this realm and,
and it's drawing down material from elsewhere.
I've had the same experience with my,
with my writing.
The more that I intellectualize the process and that's particularly true since
I've turned to fiction,
the more that I intellectualize the process,
the,
the harder the writing becomes and the sooner,
the sooner I let let off that intellectual control and just let it flow the
better.
Again,
it's so strange how it comes in waves though.
It's almost like you,
you can't keep tuned into the spiritual realm for any long period of time.
I shake it off.
I know after like a few hours of writing,
my writing just starts to turn to shit and I'm like,
oh,
I guess it's off now.
It's back to me.
I was me writing and the right thing to do at that point is,
is actually to say the laptop,
the laptop,
go,
go and have a break.
You can save your work and try again tomorrow.
It's universal.
You know,
there's a Steven Pressfield's book,
the war of art that deals with the concept of the muse and it's a fantastic
book.
And I used to buy stacks of them and give them to people.
I gave you one right?
Amending that.
I'm a big fan of Pressfield.
I didn't know he'd written that.
It's a brilliant book.
You know,
I think I have a copy of it.
I will give you one.
Um,
and it's,
um,
the brilliant thing about it is it's really no nonsense,
but it's all about,
it's a no nonsense doing,
put the work in,
force yourself to do it.
Don't make excuses,
put the work in.
But then it's also about the muse.
It's also about the idea that you are just sitting there and putting yourself in
a position to tune into it.
You just have to show up.
You show up,
you move your fingers,
you the let the muse come to you.
And that the muse is,
yeah.
Well,
let me tell you,
I mean,
I have been,
uh,
a nonfiction writer all my life.
Um,
I started out,
as I mentioned in journalism,
I moved into ancient mysteries,
but it was always nonfiction.
You look at book like fingerprints of the Gods or underworld,
the book about our art diving adventures,
and you'll find that there's 2000 footnotes,
you know,
um,
the very,
that they are,
I hope they're readable,
but they're also,
you know,
detailed research documents.
Um,
and that was the kind of,
that was the kind of writer I was until I encountered Iowasca.
Uh,
and when I encountered Iowasca,
I had,
I started working with [inaudible] in 2003.
And the reason I started working,
I had to had one psychedelic experience,
uh,
in 1974 with LSD.
And after that,
it was an amazing experience,
by the way.
I had an app most incredible night at the Windsor Free Festival in England.
I spent the whole night wandering around.
They had,
I kind of traveled back in time.
It was like being in a sort of medieval in camp.
It's just incredible.
But when I came out of that experience,
I thought to myself,
hmm,
I was 20 I guess I was 24.
Then I thought if that went the other way,
that was a really powerful experience.
If that went the other way,
I'm not sure how I would handle it.
I thought it might really fuck me up.
And I,
and I got a bit scared and I,
and I,
and I'd heard stories of others who tad scary experiences.
And I thought,
I'm not,
I'm not to do that again.
And I didn't,
I didn't,
I didn't take any psychedelics from the age of 24 until,
let's see,
2003 when I was 53 years old.
And the reason that I started taking psychedelics again was because,
um,
initially it was my research project.
I was writing supernatural.
It was clear that the cave art had been influenced by psychedelics.
Here was something I could experience for myself.
I've always felt as a writer,
and I shouldn't be writing something if I'm not in it myself,
I have to experience it,
which is why when you were writing underworlds you learned how to dive diving
and,
and ended up doing huge numbers of knives all,
all,
all around the world.
It's the way that I work and therefore it was logical for me to investigate
psychedelics once I started to write supernatural and I wanted to investigate
them in a shamonic setting.
Um,
I looked around the research,
the subject,
and it became clear that the Amazon was the place to go and Iowasca with
thousands of years of indigenous use in the Amazon was a very,
very interesting substance indeed to,
uh,
to,
to investigate.
So,
you know,
I went down there and,
um,
started to drink Ayahuasca.
IOWASCA worked changes on me in quite a number of ways.
It's made me more thoughtful and reflective person in some ways about my
behavior and the impact of my behavior on others.
I'm still got a long way to go on that.
They say in the Amazon that [inaudible] is a school,
uh,
don't expect,
you know,
instant enlightenment.
Actually all enlightenment is hard work and the hard work with Iowasca is
integrating the revelations that it gives you.
Cause it will,
of the things that I was good does is she does show you where you've been cruel
and hurtful and unkind to others and she shows it you from the other person's
point of view.
Um,
it's a lesson that you learn and,
and,
but then integrating that into your own behavior in daily life is actually
really difficult.
Lifetime of bad habits are very hard to change.
Uh,
and work has to be done in order to do that.
so I'll ask a house helped me to begin on that path.
I do not claim to have reached any form of perfection very far from it.
I'm a very imperfect,
frail human being,
but I have at least been set on the path that I believe is a more positive one.
But then something else I wanna ask.
It gave me,
and it happened because I asked for it.
I had reached a point where I felt that I didn't want to go on with the
investigation of the lost civilization subject anymore.
Not because I had lost interest in it or because I turned against it,
but because I felt that I'd taken it as far as I personally could after Santa
and I had done six years of scuba diving all around the world and literally put
our lives on the line and had and had revealed a great deal of stuff under water
that people didn't know about.
I felt,
actually,
I don't know where I take this next.
I,
there are a lot of young,
energetic people out there.
I would like them to take it on now for where,
where,
where I took it from and I wanted,
I wanted to look for a change of direction and I wanted to challenge myself as a
writer and I'd always wanted to write an awful,
so down in Brazil,
uh,
over a series of five Iowasca sessions.
I,
I asked,
I will ask her,
can I write a novel and if so,
what would I be writing about?
And something amazing happened in those five sessions.
I was given the entire story of the novel that I ended up writing,
which is a novel called entangled and the whole story,
the characters,
their dilemmas,
the time travel aspect of it,
the story just frantically writing it all down or would you try to remember?
It was very,
I wasn't even trying to remember it.
It was just very,
very clear,
was very clear that I was to write a story and that would involve two young
women,
one in the Stone Age,
one in the modern times,
and that they would be entangled,
that they would be connected through consciousness,
um,
and that they would be involved in a,
in a battle of good against evil.
And certain scenes came through very,
very clear to me and step vividly in my mind.
So as soon as we'd finished in Brazil,
I went back to England and started writing.
So when you ask Iowasca can you do it and what would it be about?
Do you think that this,
that Iowasca wants you to do this because with,
if you do something like that,
you have to,
I always think of any work that I put out,
whether it's even writing a blog or putting something,
a funny thing up on Twitter,
you send out this signal and then the signals going to effect who knows how many
people in a positive way,
especially something that they really enjoy reading like a book and people can
say like,
why would I want if you want you to write a book because some books are fucking
awesome.
That's why,
and that
that feeling of getting really hooked into a book and really just loving it.
I haven't read a good novel in a while.
The strain was the last one that I really liked for a while,
but then hated,
you know,
I love the beginning of it.
That's that vampire one,
the bunny,
the Gwen [inaudible] del Toro Book.
Anyway,
my point is you that feeling there's all a lot of positive energy associated
with something that's really entertaining and gripping.
Yeah,
definitely.
There's time.
He was a highly effective way of a way it way of communicating.
I don't know whether a Iowasca did this for me,
but you,
they often say there's a song that I forget the song,
you know,
the rolling stones,
you don't always get what you want.
You get what you need,
you know,
I ask,
uh,
does does that she tends to give you what you need,
not always what you asked for.
I have set intense at the beginning of sessions and I found myself going in a
totally different direction,
but these five sessions were different.
It was very,
very clear.
Here is a story,
go home and write it.
It was very,
I felt compelled to do it.
So,
so if they affected you in that way,
they created this huge effect on,
you think about what would happen if it was legally available.
If people where they excel,
then you see how the war on drugs is actually suppressing a human evolution.
Yeah.
If this is I,
it seems like you're saying that,
um,
throughout time I,
the psychedelics had been widened or do you think they objections were taking
psychedelics?
Definitely,
definitely.
What psychedelics do,
we take
particularly the blue water lily and in fair,
sorry,
Leah,
um,
which is a potent psychedelic and William amber done at the State University of
California has,
um,
uh,
published a detailed research on,
on the blue water lily and on it's psychedelic properties.
And it was certainly used a,
they were journeyers they though when the ancient Egyptians explored the mystery
of life after death,
they were not,
uh,
you know,
sitting in some scribal room just making this stuff up.
They were investigating,
they were exploring,
they were separating that consciousness from the body and they were entering
other realms and they were coming back and giving a detailed report about what
they encountered there.
The first I'd ever heard of any of that was from John Anthony West work and the
work on the temple of man.
Yeah.
Which is really fascinating that there's a temple in each area of the temple
signifies like a part of a human being.
And there's a whole area about the pineal gland and the,
the,
the Egyptians were,
you know,
they called it the seed of the soul and that they believed that,
the pineal gland was your connection to,
to the afterlife.
Yeah.
Hey,
hey,
they were right.
Yeah.
You know,
this is,
cause this is the,
this is the mystery that a DMT,
which is the active ingredient of Iowasca,
uh,
is generated by the pineal gland.
They believe that,
yeah,
totally.
It was Rick Strassman's hunch.
But,
but,
uh,
something in our bodies and the pineal gland is the most likely suspect.
That's a big,
is sticking point with generating DMT because the presence of DMT in the human
body is not in dispute.
What it's coming from is in dispute,
but it's presence in the body is not in dispute.
Just sounds cool.
It really comes from the pineal gland,
kind of sounds kind of cool.
It comes from the third eye,
particularly since the pineal gland is a,
is,
um,
uh,
what was originally a sense organ.
And so the suggestion would be that it's still a sense organ to kind of sixth
sense.
Uh,
which,
uh,
the lens that it uses is DMT.
And when people don't realize is that in reptiles and certain reptiles that
actually has a retina in a lens and it's light sensitive,
there's a fucking eyeball.
It's light sensitive.
Yes.
In reptiles,
in humans.
It's not,
it's deep.
It's deeper into the brain.
Um,
but,
but a very mysterious,
very mysterious organ.
And,
uh,
I would still say I,
you're right,
it's not proven.
I would still say the most likely candidate for the,
for the generation of DMT Strassman is working on figuring that out right now.
And they're working on more detailed studies to try to excellent.
Exactly.
Pinpoint the location.
Excellent.
It's where it's created.
This is,
I'm glad that that's happening.
I mean,
the,
you know,
the point that,
that you were making just now.
I think that,
I think that by cutting these,
um,
ancient plant allies out of our life,
uh,
and,
and by demonizing them and creating this atmosphere of fear and hatred around
them,
this is a suicidal path that our society is taking.
And we only need to look at the past in order to realize that that is true.
There is a danger in the human species that we get locked into a particular
frame and right now we are locked into the technology frame.
Of course we're advancing technology very,
very,
very fast,
but that doesn't mean we aren't locked.
We're locked into one frame and we are not thinking outside of that frame and,
and we can see the consequences of being locked into that frame,
which is our world is in chaos.
Our world is in,
in a,
in a state of hatred and fear and suspicion right now there's,
there's all this horrible stuff going on and we are literally on the edge of
destroying ourselves.
And there's never been a time in the human story when we've more needed to break
out of our rigid patterns of behavior and start thinking about things from a
different point of view.
And Nature has provided us with the means to do so.
And those means are our plant allies,
right?
Yeah.
It's a fascinating concept and the concept that human beings are working against
themselves and they're working to keep things fucked up and make them more.
And that the only way to sustain a society as complex and large and visa as the
one we currently live in,
the only ways to do it,
the way we're doing it.
And that if all of a sudden psychedelic drugs were introduced in the materialism
was,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
pushed in the back burner and spiritualism was something that people,
you know,
started really understanding and appreciating their connection more.
Who the fuck's gonna go to work?
Yeah.
It was,
was going to be chilling all the chickens we need sort of chicken mcnuggets
yeah,
Nick's would become very different,
but the fact is that our existing economic model is falling apart at the seams
anyway.
And people are living in misery and doubt and chaos and confusion because it's
just not working.
It's not working,
is it?
The whole thing is not working.
Any society that can stand back while the Amazon jungle is burnt down at the
sort of countryside rate every year.
Uh,
this is an insane society.
We obviously live in a demented society.
Completely insane.
A lot of people aren't even aware of how crazy that looks.
If you watch it.
And you know,
you see documentaries on online of the mass amounts of forests,
they're chopping down.
It's a bizarre,
that's why,
that's why it's interesting.
But this particular agent I'll ask her,
comes from the Amazon,
you know,
I can't help,
I can't help feeling in the Amazon.
They strongly believed that an intelligent entity lies behind the Iowasca of
mine.
She,
she,
they always speak of her as she,
most of the cultures do,
um,
is using the vine as an access point to humanity.
Um,
and,
and um,
oh,
I just lost my thread.
How did I get to that?
Well,
we're talking about Amazon.
Yeah.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
That,
that at the very time when our western technological culture is,
uh,
is responsible for mass destruction in the Amazon,
which it is.
And by the way,
it's a problem that could be easily solved.
We don't need to destroy the Amazon.
We really don't need those soya bean farms in the Amazon to feed cattle so that
people can eat hamburgers.
Ma,
we much more need the rainforest,
you know,
so at the very time that the Amazon is under threat from the western way of
life,
which has infected almost every culture on the planet at that very time,
the Amazon is sending out it's emissary in the form of the vine of souls who is
kind of extending her coiled sinuous self all around the world and reaching into
human consciousness everywhere because Iowasca is being drunk all around the
world.
Yeah,
I know.
I have.
I've met someone on Facebook who takes it regularly.
There's a cop,
it's a cop and you're going to jail.
That's not,
that's no cop.
He knits like,
what do they call it?
The should bobo or if there's a name should be,
he knits these patterns like he like he showed there like they net the exact
things you were saying that are on the cave walls,
like the honeycomb patterns and stuff.
So they like create these beautiful quilts.
Is it quilted damage that are just incredible depictions of the what apparently
the Ioi do geometric aspect of it.
Do you ever think of how much you play a part of that?
Does that ever focus in on your mind?
I mean your instincts obviously were to produce this book and to talk about it
very openly and honestly and to do interviews like this and you'll have
discussions like this where you talk about it and you know this right now is
going to reach half a million people.
They're going to consider what you're saying and they're going to look into it
and they're going to let go.
Whoa.
Do you really think that there's some fucking vine you can take from the jungle
that allows you to communicate with the spirit world?
I feel when you find out that the responsibility in this area,
let's
explain to people what it does for,
for,
for noobs,
for Google,
are not aware of what I lost is the first thing I'd like to say is that,
uh,
that Iowasca and as a matter of fact,
all psychedelics are very serious business.
Um,
I,
I personally do not believe that psychedelics are appropriate for recreational
activity.
I think if somebody chooses to do that,
that's their body.
That's their choice.
But I don't think it's the right thing to do.
We need to treat these amazing substances with respect.
Um,
and it's anybody who's worked with psychedelics will know absolutely.
The set and setting in which the psychedelic is consumed is as important as the
psychedelic itself.
Absolutely.
What you've prepared,
what you are looking for from the experience and the company in which you take
it.
And the reason for which you take it are definitely going to color and affect
the experience.
And um,
I think it's a,
I think it's a mistake to use these powerful agents of,
of consciousness work,
um,
for recreation.
There are other great things for recreation and,
and,
and another great central subjects sort of substances.
But,
but,
uh,
the psychedelics are not for that purpose.
And,
and,
and if somebody wants to have a really bad trip and have and have truly horrific
experiences with psychedelics,
take it in the wrong set and setting and you can be pretty sure that's going to
happen to you sooner or later.
So I was,
the first thing I would say to people with,
with all psychedelics is be careful.
This is this respect,
respect,
deep respect for this.
This is a,
this is a very serious thing you're engaging on.
Therefore,
um,
find,
uh,
fi find a space that can be protected.
Find somebody who knows what they're doing,
who can sit with you and who can oversee the CW and bring a ceremony to the,
to the table.
Let's not just a sit down disrespectfully,
disrespectfully and consume the substance.
Let's,
uh,
let's bring a ceremonial aspect to it.
And I would say with Iowasca,
I know that quite a number of people now have started to get the ingredients on
the Internet and brew up their Ios Guy.
I honestly think that's a mistake.
There are people who are enormously experienced working with Iowasca.
They are the Shamans from the Amazon.
More and more Western.
Those are being trained by those Shamaz.
Those Westerners are returning to western countries and are creating a new form
of shamanism relevant to the urban and industrial context of the,
of the West.
If you really want to work with IOWASCA,
seek out somebody like that better still if you can,
if you can get the funds together,
go down to Brazil.
I've got down to Peru and work with the masters,
but,
but you find the masters if you want to do that.
Um,
well it's all word of mouth.
There's a,
there is a huge network.
I'm,
I'm often reminded of sort of underground sects at the end of the Roman empire,
like the Gnostics,
you know,
being persecuted by the,
by,
by mainstream Christianity where everything was done by word of mouth.
It's like that with Iowasca now.
Um,
generally speaking,
if you feel drawn to the vine,
do some serious research on the subject and you will find your way to the,
to the right people.
There are some charlatans working in this field,
there are in all fields,
but there are also some very good people.
And,
and do some serious research first
and look into the subject and find the right person,
somebody who is deeply experienced,
who understands the vine and work with them and you can be sure you're going to
have a much more worthwhile experience.
Whatever series of events led you to go there and take those substances and have
these visionary experiences and then relay them.
Do you ever feel as if you were compelled that you are brought to it?
Like this is like a,
you,
you have a purpose.
Do you feel that way?
Um,
I,
if so,
it's like the rest of the course of my life.
A series of accidents.
Like I flew into that city in northern Ethiopia in 1983 and found myself in
front of a monk who said he had the Ark of the covenant behind him.
It turned the direction in my life.
And okay.
I decided that after,
after I published underworld,
which was my last book on the lost civilization issues.
Um,
I had always been interested in human origins and that's why I decided to write
supernatural.
But when I got into the subject,
I found that the story didn't get interesting until 50,000 years ago.
And it got interesting because of psychedelics.
And then,
so it wasn't an accident that led me to that then,
or obvious.
The next research conclusion was I had to go take some psychedelics and to do so
in a shamonic setting and learn about it.
So I,
it was a series of accidental decisions,
kind of led me,
led me to that process.
So I,
I guess I don't feel cold or chosen,
but I,
but,
but I found myself in the hot seat.
Do you feel obligated them?
Because you know so much about it?
Because I feel obligated.
I feel,
and I feel a responsibility,
uh,
which is,
which is to,
um,
is to share with others that these,
these agents can be transformational and that and that they can be incredibly
helpful.
Um,
but that they are also extremely powerful and that they must be treated with
respect.
And Xero is real.
And here's,
here's the thing,
everyone is running around looking for magic.
Everyone is running around looking for a religious experience.
And you can have that.
You really can,
it is a real thing.
It doesn't care whether you believe in it or don't believe in it.
It's not dogmatic.
It is a legit thing.
Oh yeah.
And if you take it,
you'll have an experience that you cannot believe is real and available.
You cannot believe that it's so easy that you drink this substance and all of a
sudden you,
you literally enter into some different dimension.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's,
it's,
it,
it is real.
And that's why the,
it's really not a matter for intellectual speculation.
It's a direct experience that it can have.
And then what you make of the experiences is really what matters.
It's all,
it's like you're the people who ridicule it.
You'll like my,
you know,
when,
when people mock mushrooms like,
Hey,
I've even talked to Michio Kaku who's this amazing physicist and it's really
brilliant guy.
And I was on the OB and Anthony Show and I asked him if you're done mushrooms
and he,
you know,
said like,
I was like,
I was a fool.
He was acting like I was a fool.
Like it was a silly person.
No,
I need my mind to be intact and all this stuff so I can work on,
since he's never done mushrooms,
how could he know what it does to his mind?
This is,
this is prejudice at work.
I'm like,
my God man,
this what if it was real,
if it was real,
would you trust me?
Would you,
if,
if it,
if I told you that there was some real thing and you take it and you're going to
be in communication with some insanely wise entity from some parallel or
constantly surrounding you dimension.
What'd you just try when you just try it?
And
he convinced that's the problem that we're talking about years because,
ah,
Michio Kaku,
he is a genius.
Super juvies conditioned.
And so now imagine if a genius came in contact with something because right now
this spirit,
whatever you want to call it,
it's right now the majority of a lot of the people it's contacting or like 16
year olds in trailers.
Who or why they were like playing Xbox.
Yeah.
It's like I am trying to communicate.
High level information.
Why are you sending me he a kid?
To be fair,
I have to,
I have to say that,
that um,
that uh,
I'm not sure that's the case with Iowasca.
No,
I think that mushroom quite a whole number of reasons for sure.
Mushrooms for sure.
But,
but it's not the case with Ios.
Yeah.
It's too difficult for it.
I WASC is really a mission.
I mean you have to brace yourself.
Uh,
I was uh,
is hard work.
Uh,
I will ask a,
we'll make you vomit.
It will give you diarrhea.
They call it the purge in the Amazon and it is a,
an enormously effective PEGA DIV agent.
Take my word for it.
Yeah.
We still have explained to the noobs to people who really have no idea what
we're talking about.
Um,
with,
with Iowasca is,
is an orally active version of DMT.
And that these amazing people from was how,
how far does it date back?
How many thousands of years archaeological evidence for the use of Iowasca going
back more than 4,000 years in the Amazon.
And so somehow or another 4,000 years ago,
out of hundreds of thousands of different plants,
right.
They figured out,
I combined the vine of one with the leaves of another and sophisticated piece of
chemistry.
But they're doing explain to people what it is.
Yeah.
So the ask,
it consists of three ingredients.
One of them is water,
the medium in which it's brewed.
And the other two are a leaf.
That leaf is from a plant called psychiatry of the Redis is the botanical name,
the college Chacruna in the Amazon.
And that leaf contains a pharmacologically pure dimethyltryptamine,
a contains DMT,
which should your own body makes.
What's your own buddy?
Max.
And uh,
with that,
uh,
with the empty,
you have a problem because DMT is not orally active.
And the reason that DMT is not orally active is that we have an enzyme in our
stomachs called mano a amine oxidase and monoamine oxidase switches off DMT on
contact.
What they did in the Amazon jungle was that they found out of,
actually there's,
you're right,
there's 150,000 different species of plants and trees in the Amazon they found
the one other that contains a monoamine oxidase inhibitor is that's what the
vine contains.
The vine actually does not contain the psychedelic ingredient.
It contains the ingredient that allows the psychedelic to become orally active.
So do you think they just ate the two of them at the same time once and
had some crazy experience and when will you write this down?
It's about this.
They all say the same thing.
The spirits taught our ancestors to do this.
When these guys are getting blasted Iowasca for decades upon decades though,
do you think they could really recall exactly how they learned all this?
They didn't lay into that lifetimes because it was already old knowledge to
them.
They're speaking of their,
of their ancestors.
And they literally say that the plant's spoke to them.
Right.
They told us about how to do it and reached out to them and said,
put this together when it had to be during the,
well it had to be at least as recent as they figured out how to harness fire to
cook it.
Yeah.
You need,
she need a metal.
Correct.
Like need a pile.
No,
no.
What kind of pot do you cook it and you can use ceramic ceramic so it could
predate metal.
Yeah,
definitely predates,
definitely predates metal.
Yeah,
no doubt about that.
It's an amazing thing that they've combined.
Do you think that it's not orally active because it's in so many different
plants that if it was that people would just be eating and getting higher DMT
all the time.
Nature is our friend in these matters.
Nature looks after us and,
and uh,
that may be the case,
uh,
that it's not so widely distributed.
The mystery is that it is present in quite a lot actually.
Um,
and,
uh,
that mixed with an,
with a monoamine oxidase inhibitor,
you end up with an orally active substance and does that,
would that work if you wanted to?
And I of course a hundred percent agree with you that you should,
um,
go to a sham and if you're going to do this experience,
but if you did have that leaf that you are talking about and just a classic Mao
inhibitor or whatever it was and you took that and eight the leaf,
would you then have the experience very dangerous though?
Yeah.
It's kind of does.
You should do,
you would have,
but there are a,
what they call Iowasca analogs,
which,
uh,
and,
and even farmer Wasco is being spoken of now,
which does precisely that,
which uses a pharmacological AI,
uh,
you know,
with DMT.
Um,
uh,
I think,
I think personally we don't need to go there because nature has provided us with
this beautiful and incredible,
uh,
possibility in the,
in the Iowasca brew in these,
in these two different plants.
Interestingly,
um,
it's,
uh,
not impossible to drink IOWASCA legally in the United States.
Um,
because the battle is already being fought here.
The there in Brazil,
um,
the IOWASCA shamanism has come out of the jungle and into the cities and it's
taken form,
uh,
of,
several what'd you would call syncretic churches,
which are mixing elements of Christianity with elements of traditional
shamanism.
So the best known are the Santo Daime,
me and the uni,
our division of tile,
um,
which both use Iowasca as their sacrament.
I've sat down with the Juniata vegetal group in Brazil and drink IOWASCA.
They were the most charming,
thorough,
professional,
hardworking people I could ever have hoped to meet.
They bring their children to the sessions,
they start their children on Iowasca at the age of 14.
They have a completely different view of psychedelics to the view that we have.
They,
they believe that it's really helpful and important experience for humanity to
have this.
And fortunately the government of Brazil agrees with them and it doesn't
persecute them for,
for doing this.
So they have formed a established churches and those churches have members in
the United States.
And I think it started in New Mexico.
The matter was taken up to the Supreme Court and the Supreme Court said,
yes,
if you're a member of the unit or division Todd,
you can drink iowasca legally.
Now that actually for somebody who wants to work with Iowasca is something that
I would recommend.
I personally don't,
I'm not drawn to establish churches of any kind.
I believe that spirituality doesn't require a church,
um,
and a hierarchy.
But the fact is that the uni,
our veggies,
the veggies tile and the Santo Daime me both know what they're doing with
Iowasca.
They absolutely know what they're doing and they are present in the United
States and they're drinking.
I am ask illegally in the United States.
Strassman told me,
Strassman told me he met with them in New Mexico and he said they are all
wearing outfits and they're drinking IOWASCA and singing songs about Jesus.
And he's like,
they're on these really,
really strong IOWASCA trips and they're singing songs about Jesus.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you people doing down here?
It's such a strange hybrid of things.
Very strange.
A Trojan horse for Ios Hybrid.
Um,
but,
um,
I mean interestingly enough,
if we,
if we separate Christ off from the monstrous bureaucracy called the church,
uh,
you do find an interesting spiritual teacher,
at,
at work and I suspect through Iowasca they're getting closer to the true to the
true spiritual teachings and,
and um,
and more important,
um,
ios gay's not mediated by a priesthood.
Iowasca is your own direct experience of the spirit realm.
That's,
that's,
that's really important.
Whereas whereas in most mainstream religions,
the priesthood is telling you what to think.
They are the intermediary between us and the divine.
In the case of Iowasca,
the brew is the intermediary and it plugs us straight into the divine.
It sounds like a bad ass church to join the love
sitting in college and reading the New Testament.
That was one of my favorite things is getting really,
really are tripping and then reading the gospels because it is a very,
very psychedelic text.
The,
the book of John,
it's,
it's almost as if when you're tr,
it's hard not to read when you're sober,
but when you're tripping in the beginning was the word.
And the word was made a flash or it's just is what is that?
Then you start thinking someone wrote this,
like this wasn't,
you know,
someone really meant this when they wrote it and then you're on.
And they mean,
yeah,
a long time and it's very,
very trippy.
So I can totally understand how being on Iowa Osca from what you described,
the experience as and mixing that with Christ symbols be pretty amazing.
Along the line of with Mckenna thought of,
do you ever,
you're familiar with John Marco Legros work and the whole idea,
the Dead Sea Scrolls in the cross?
Yeah.
Very much so.
And,
and other,
again,
this has been,
this is another thing that has been erased from history.
Uh,
but the fact of the matter is that if you go into early Christianity,
what you find is a mushroom called no doubt about it whatsoever.
No doubt about it.
There are even,
um,
there are even depictions of the tree in the garden of Eden and those depictions
show a mushroom they show that they show is specifically an Amanita muscarinic
mushroom,
not a assignment.
And I'm an eighth of a scary,
also hallucinogenic mushroom.
Um,
so you know,
when,
uh,
the uh,
entity called,
uh,
you know,
Yahweh or Jehovah or whatever,
he calls himself,
you know,
drove out of an eve out of the garden of Eden.
He was driving them out of the garden of Eden because they'd done a mushroom
trip.
That makes sense.
And then the apple,
the apple is apple.
The even the word for apple also means red.
And that the mushroom,
the Ana Mendieta miscarry was a red mushroom.
And that this is what the eight,
I mean,
it makes sense.
The food of the Gods,
you know,
and the forbidden fruit.
It makes total sense.
And actually I don't believe that we can understand,
um,
any,
uh,
spirituality without,
dealing with altered states of consciousness.
This is,
um,
this is again,
something that's been lost in the modern world.
You don't find in most of the mainstream religions,
much altered state of consciousness going on.
But if you go back to the origins,
you find altered states of consciousness are,
are deeply involved.
And I'm not saying that those auto states of consciousness,
we're always caused by psychedelics.
There's other ways to get into deeply altered states of consciousness,
including starving yourself,
fasting,
austerities,
certain kinds of rhythmic dancing,
but definitely altered states of consciousness where involved.
So in the case of Christianity,
it's Saint Paul on the Damascus road,
you know,
he has this blinding revelation,
which completely turns his life around in a totally different direction.
Benny Shannon,
who's the professor of psychology at the Hebrew University in Jerusalem,
has made a very powerful case that Moses in front of the burning Bush is really
a psychedelic experience that's being described there.
And you're sitting in front of his,
the Bush and it's kind of moving and glowing and a voice is coming out of it and
speaking to you.
Uh,
it's very psychedelic experience.
And he even further argues that that Moses may have been drinking and Iowasca
analogs,
Syrian Rue and memos or hostility.
I think these are two products which contain the same ingredients as are found
in the Amazon.
But you know,
the DMT and the MRI,
which grow in the Middle East.
So that's a,
you know,
that's,
that's possible
to,
I've even heard Scott scholars connect the acacia tree or the Acacia Bush with
a,
a pot potential,
uh,
source of,
a psychedelic experience because apparently it's rich in dimethyltryptamine some
academies burning Bush,
you know,
somehow or another
like this was,
you know,
they,
they had synthesize DMT from this and burned it and then he has his experience.
So they're calling it a burning Bush.
Well,
sort of.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
If this Bush that is common to that area actually has DMT in it.
Yeah.
It's amazing with the whole thing.
Idea comes different.
So,
and so you begin to realize that,
that when you scratch the mainstream religions,
you get down to base ground before the money man in the bureaucrats stepped in
and took it over.
You find visionary experiences are at the heart of it.
They're at the essence of it.
And,
and Ben later on,
those visionary experiences become band and illegal and nobody's ever allowed to
have them again.
No.
When I want to go back to something you said earlier that you said you have
problems with technology.
Um,
and I think sort of,
uh,
you know,
a lot of people subscribe to the idea that technology sort of,
even though it brings people together and connects people,
it sort of pushing people apart too.
And it's making people become sort of desensitized to a lot of things and,
and,
and they alienated themselves and sit at home and play video games.
And do you ever consider the possibility that technology is a life form in and
of itself?
Do you ever consider the possibility that we are somehow or another locked in
some symbiotic relationship to we are the worker bees creating this new life
form technology,
artificial intelligence,
which we're absolutely working on creating will eventually be the next stage.
Something that's not hindered by the monkey flesh that really cannot evolve as
quickly as the technology camp.
I see no reason why that should not be the case.
Um,
I think that since I personally believe that that consciousness is not generated
by the brain but is an independent entity which chooses to immerse itself in
physical form,
I don't see why that entity shouldn't chose to most itself in mechanical form
either in any highly organized system.
Uh,
I don't see why consciousness should not manifest through that system.
Why are we thinking that it only is going to work in a collection of bacteria
and cells?
Yeah.
This bag of bacteria is the only one that works.
Covered a symbiotic relationship between who knows how many different types of
things in your body.
Yeah.
He Kolai and all these different things on your skin and you know,
and,
and viruses that you carried for your entire life.
Yeah.
Did you make,
have you seen the,
um,
it's on the Internet.
It's a video where they took the two artificial intelligence machines and let
them have a conversation.
Yes.
They started lying to each other.
They start lying.
I haven't seen that.
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
It's amazing.
But within a minute they're at talking about God.
Within a minute,
things are talking about God.
And that was the,
that was the first time I realized that,
oh,
you know,
I bet that our idea of this robot that the people make is more like terminator.
You know what I mean?
There's like the kind of like emotionless death machines.
Yes,
exactly.
But maybe if something super intelligent,
the first thing these machines are going to start considering is their source.
And I think,
oh,
the humans made us and they're going to think who made the humans and where did
these ideas come from?
But they're going to process the ideas we're kicking around here it a mega
speed and that's going to produce the new religion or that's going to produce
the next big whatever Jesus is going to be a robot.
The next thing you can be a,
a machine say,
I just don't have any,
a problem at all with the notion of consciousness.
I'm incarnating in a machine.
I that that seems to be perfectly,
perfectly reasonable.
Um,
and besides there's many machine like functions of the human body.
I mean Shane's too.
Yeah,
we are machines.
There's a video we've talked about before about watching traffic go back and
forth on a high speed camera,
slow motion,
rather it's our sped up brother throughout the day.
And then it looks just like cells and blood cells going down an artery
def.
Definitely.
And do you know it's very interesting.
I mean you get to the,
you get to the issue of the,
um,
the origins of life.
Um,
and,
and of course you touching on deep religious issues.
Who were we?
Were we created in,
in some way?
Um,
I think that the universe,
the,
the conclusion I'm coming to is that the,
the universe,
um,
manifests organization and life wherever it can,
as a,
as,
uh,
as a medium in which consciousness can immerse itself.
And that,
that,
that this may take many different forms and shapes with the key that was driving
it is consciousness and the need for consciousness to manifest on the physical
plane.
I mean at,
I'll make a trivial example,
but I think all of us have had this experience,
you know,
with our computers were um,
somehow there's some kind of interaction between you and your computer in some
ways it seems that,
uh,
I remember once I had,
it was,
it was the most curious thing.
I had just got a new computer and my old computer had increasingly annoyed me
because when I was saving,
when I'd finished the document on Microsoft word,
it told me that I'd made new changes,
which I needed to say,
which I hadn't done.
It kept saying,
do you want to save the changes that you've just made?
And I hadn't done that and I,
and finally with other glitches on the machine and got so annoying,
I decided to get myself another computer and that computer was working fine and
I was sitting in front of it one day and I was thinking how awful it would be if
it started manifesting that same fault and instantly the same fault came up on
my computer.
It did that
I couldn't help feeling this as shitty Microsoft coding yet actually.
But it was reacting to it.
Nevertheless,
the way it reacted to my thought was odd.
And,
and um,
you know,
I animals,
most people,
most,
most people would argue perhaps humans have a soul,
but animals don't have assault.
I think we're all soul.
I think soul consciousness is the essence of everything.
And I think it manifests in,
in all forms,
just incredibly lucky that we have manifested in human bodies because we've got
this body with its equipment is an incredible opportunity for learning and
growing and developing.
And we've got much better opportunity to learn and grow and develop then a fruit
fly or a cockroach.
Does.
Do you ever looked in any rubric Sheldrake's work or remarkable man,
fascinating work.
The idea that everything has
some sort of a memory to it.
Yes.
Yeah.
And perhaps even a consciousness to it.
More.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And he's,
um,
he's doing really good science on a really metaphysical subjects right now.
One of the few people who's,
who's,
who's doing that.
So He's,
he's looked at phenomena like the sense of being stared at.
People know when they're being stared at even when they can't see the person
who's staring at them and the phenomenon of animals knowing when their master is
going to come home.
Even when the master himself doesn't quite know yet.
They,
he's studying that in a very scientific way and he's producing statistically
significant results which show that these phenomena definitely do it.
Boyd and people fight at him to the nail.
I've read some of the critiques of his work is so,
so angry.
Yeah.
Oh people get so frustrated.
Angry.
Cause again it's a,
it's kind of throwing
the existing paradigm upside down,
thrown in the air and saying that that we're all connected by these
morphogenetic fields
and it's not showing a perfect connection either.
It's showing a measurable one,
it's showing something,
there's something there,
there's something there and it's probably increasing and evolving.
Just like our ability to communicate was grunts and noises and then eventually
evolved into the written word and you know,
and now cd's and mp3s,
it's,
it's all evolving and our ability to sense when people are staring at us is
probably something that's evolving.
There's probably energy that comes off of you when you look at me and I just,
I can,
I can sense it when I'm looking away.
Yeah,
makes sense.
I mean,
it totally makes sense.
Yeah.
It's so strange.
It's so strange that these are all things that people struggle to consider.
And then if you do talk about them and you're a serious guy,
but if you talk about them,
you run into Cooksville.
Now all of a sudden you're,
I mean,
you went so deep into Cooksville that you wrote a book about March did,
and this is,
this is where you really take a chance.
Lost a lot of my readers there.
Did you?
Yes.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
but,
you know,
it seemed to me,
it seemed to be an interesting subject that was worthy of exploration at that
book was called the Mars mystery.
It was written with Robert Bovard junk,
John Grigsby
and this is the one I bought it,
but I did not read this one.
Does this have a lot to do with side Donia and the face on Mars and all that
stuff you'd
think?
Um,
but we try to set those in context.
Uh,
I do think down is extremely interesting.
Um,
what,
I mean,
my part of that book was mainly about cosmic cataclysms.
It's clear that the planet,
Planet Mars,
uh,
has been subjected to the most horrific disaster.
Uh,
and that there is some scientific evidence with suggest.
This may have been pretty recent,
like the last 20,000 years.
I mean,
wow.
Half of the planet is like a mile higher than the other half.
So if you measure,
you take,
uh,
a little ball and you cut the line round its equator and then you peel off the
outer layer of the lower half and then you leave the upper half as it as it was.
There's a cliff of mile high runs all the way around Mars.
And,
uh,
as something dramatic and disastrous happened to that planet,
there was definitely water that planet flowing water and something took it away.
Um,
very,
very horrible.
Cosmic catechism occurred,
sort of struck by a gigantic asteroid or comet most likely.
Um,
and uh,
we have these odd ruins or what look like ruins,
uh,
which NASA behaves very oddly about,
on the planet Mars.
And I just think it's an extremely interesting mystery.
And I decided to try to put my mind to work on this mystery and CFA could add
anything to the debate.
I thought it's interesting until,
ah,
what do you mean behaved badly?
Sorry,
sorry.
Wait,
which NASA behave?
So yes.
Well,
because because um,
uh,
NASA is,
um,
has consistently ridiculed the notion that there might be,
there might be intelligently created artifacts on Mars and that seems to be a
most unscientific proposition.
Um,
we have all,
we have our photographs and on the basis of those photographs,
it's not good to assume that they are monuments or that they are not monuments.
We need to keep an open mind tech take there.
We were talking earlier about the Yana Goonie underwater monument.
I mean you can actually bring two geologists to that monument.
You can put them in front of it for half an hour and they'll come away with
completely different opinions about what it is.
So,
so how can we form really useful opinions on the basis of photography alone?
You know who fucks this up?
Hoagland?
Well,
guy goes too deep.
He gets too crazy.
Richard Hoagland,
he's one of the guys who's invested a huge chunk of his life to proving that
side.
Donia is an artificially created complex and he makes these giant leaps in these
weird connections where he measures like random distances between points and now
and shows that they have a direct correlation between distances that can be
measured on in Egypt and the Giza plateau or will you measure the,
you try to follow where he's going.
You're like,
God,
this is just riddled with confirmation bias.
It's riddled with this idea that you know,
you're trying to find this connection.
You know it's,
yeah,
there's some stuff there that looks unusual.
The face,
you want to have a face kind of looks like a mountain to me.
But what's odd is the shape of it.
It's,
it's,
it is odd that it's,
it's kind of symmetrical but beg to differ.
I think that,
I think that Richard Hoagland,
his work's important and I think he's,
um,
I think he's shown great courage in,
uh,
putting his neck on the line.
Uh,
whether he's right or whether he's wrong,
this is a subject that's worthy of,
um,
of exploration.
I certainly agree with that,
but I don't agree with how he approaches things sometimes.
You know,
you know,
sometimes what happens is you get this polarization when you get,
when you get extreme academic positions,
no,
we will not listen to this.
We will not believe this.
We could do not accept any of this.
It's total rubbish.
It tends to make you more extreme on the other side as well.
You get,
you,
you get crazy from the resistance and,
and,
and you need to,
you know,
you need to keep on,
you need to keep on pushing.
So he needs someone behind them,
giving them a back rub.
And settled down.
Richard was like crazy.
I,
I'd like to say [inaudible] in my opinion.
Richard is a good man and a good researcher.
I think he's,
I think he's done.
I think he's done important work on Mars.
And um,
and those who,
those who,
who put Richard Down maybe eating their words in 10 or 20 years time,
that's me.
I'm ready.
My words,
that's not my community and I'm sorry,
I'm a professional shirt darker.
I can't help it.
There's something to be booked.
Find out,
especially the guy believes,
you know,
there's a face on Mars and all that.
You know,
there's some of the things that I think are very compelling.
Five sided pyramids or some other structures that,
not saying he's right or he's wrong.
I'm saying the question needed
to be asked and then it needed to be asked forcefully because it's up against
resistance and it needed to be asked in a way that would engage the public
imagination.
And when you say what you said earlier,
it doesn't seem unreasonable at all.
If you say that half of Mars is like literally destroyed a mile lower,
well obviously something kind of Klinsmann captain and then the absolute proof,
they've already found that there's water on Mars and there has been flowing
rivers.
There's all sorts of evidence of that.
Why not structures?
Shit.
If their structures here,
how amazing would it be if just 50 60,000 years ago there was a goddamn
civilization right up there on Mars for real.
And then we were existing at the same time they were existing and then we had
parallel development.
Could be some interaction.
This is,
this is,
this is an interesting
question.
Is a question worth asking?
It's a question and,
and,
and I'm,
I'm glad that somebody was prepared to devote,
you know,
half of his life to,
to exploring and investigating.
Even if he's wrong.
I'm glad that he was,
it's not even that he's wrong,
it's just he goes crazy art bell on Ya.
You know,
where he absolutely knows and this is unproven and you know,
you're like,
oh,
I can say it's the,
it's the polarization effect.
It's totally makes sense.
I mean,
I would imagine it's got to be incredibly difficult to be taken seriously with
any of this stuff.
And you have shown incredible bravery and putting forth all this stuff.
Cause I mean a lot of shit.
I'm sure you have
man.
A lot.
I mean,
the worst was the worst was um,
really being set up by the BBC.
I signed that.
I was going to bring that up if it came up.
I mean that in a way it's an,
I suppose it's,
yeah,
kind of oblique honor that a BBC horizon,
which is their flagship science program,
uh,
chose to spend three quarters of $1 million destroying my reputation.
Um,
but that's what,
that's what happened now six weeks before I heard from them,
I got a call from a friend in television and he said,
Graham,
you're going to get a call from horizon and they're going to ask you to appear
in interview on a show about you.
And here's my advice.
Say,
no,
they're going to stitch you up.
The whole thing is intended from the beginning as an operation to destroy you.
What's the motivation?
And you will not get a fair hearing.
And he said,
the best thing you can do is just not do that show.
So when they rang me up,
I immediately said yes,
yes.
[inaudible] was their motivation for this Troy?
Well,
the motivation was clear.
Yeah.
And I learned about this afterwards,
which was a,
a group of academics from various in Britain had written to the BBC.
And so this man Hancock is leading our students to question our archeology and
he's totally irresponsible and he's just writing popular books for the public,
but he's having such an impact.
He needs to be stopped and we need a program about him,
which really shows how full of shit he is basically about or done.
So,
and that was the agenda of the program from the beginning was not to give a fair
hearing to the ideas that I'd explored,
but to,
uh,
demonstrate that I was full of Shit.
And,
uh,
it was very difficult to get any kind of fairness in that situation,
especially when in the cutting room,
ah,
dirty tricks were played.
And that's why I,
Robert Navarro was also on that program with me and he and I took,
uh,
the BBC to the Broadcasting Standards Commission.
Uh,
and it was the first time in 35 years of broadcasting of horizon that they were
found at fault.
They were found to have produced an unfair program.
We listed 10 points of unfairness.
Only one of them was accepted as unfair by the broadcasting commission.
Nevertheless,
it was the first time in the history of that program that they were actually
found to have been deliberately unfair to mega rich and they would blow,
they were obliged to re edit the program and produce a second version of it,
which was fairer in quite a number of ways.
I actually think that the other nine points we raised where were right as well,
but the 10th one was the one that we really caught them out towards John and,
well,
this was to do with the Orion correlation and the fact that they had,
they had,
um,
uh,
not presented our side of the story.
They'd simply presented the academic side of the story and they had not allowed
us to answer this was a,
this was unfair,
so that an impression was created that we had no answer to this objection.
I saw the documentary or whatever you want to call it.
It was horrible.
It was a real attack piece.
But then I also read your response to it,
which really kind of covered every single area that they,
and then you read your response,
you go,
oh wow.
Yeah.
I mean it's really amazing that they were able to put together that,
that sort of a,
a biased bullshit piece on you.
But my response,
you know,
was read by a tiny fraction of the people who actually,
who actually saw the show and that show actually did have a devastating effect
on stilled today's this day.
Some somebody put it on my message board when I said that you were going to be
on the podcast when it was being discussed.
Somebody put it on the message board,
but luckily someone else had your,
your response to it and then it was better that it was,
was it Jay?
John West actually pointed out of them
time cause he wrote a letter at the BBC two BBC would crow,
you know,
they were trying to say,
oh well only one of the 10 points was unfair.
So that's not,
that's not too bad.
And,
and the point John Westworld made was no,
that's the only point that you were able to really get caught out on.
It's like they caught our Capone out on tax evasion,
but he doesn't mean he was innocent of all the other things he was accused of.
John Anthony West gets stuck on the outside because he doesn't have a degree.
Right.
Is that what's going on with him?
He's not an easy,
he's not a professionally qualified egyptologist,
but he's the best egyptologist I know.
It's brilliant.
There's magical Egypt DVD series,
rentable.
Wonderful.
John's a great man.
I watched that DVD series Noblesse than 20 times over and over at my wife was
getting,
she was yelling at me.
She's like,
I can't believe you're watching magical Egypt again.
And then she was like,
you're crazy.
You're a crazy person.
I'm like,
this is fascinating.
Do you know what they knew?
You know how much they knew.
This is incredible.
Look at a John.
Yeah.
John West has done fantastic work on Egypt and anybody who's traveling to Egypt
get hold of John West's travelers key to ancient Egypt,
which is by far by,
by a planetary distance,
the best guide book that's ever been written on Egypt because that will plunge
you into the mystery of Egypt in a way that no other books
it does.
Yeah.
His work is incredible.
Three car,
you
go and do Ios,
get ceremonies in the Amazon.
Hmm.
And
deep sea diving and dangerous.
He's a real Indiana Jones man.
This is Indiana Jones.
They were real close like you're,
you're a prime candidate for,
for somebody who's probably going to get sucked into some kind of vortex thing.
Yeah.
You might just manage sometimes that might just have,
it is an incredible a resume.
When you think about it,
the fact that you,
the description of those dives,
man about the current,
yeah.
The BBC thing.
The reason I bring that up is because it's not as though you're just studying
foggy pictures or you're just looking at it or reading information and then
coming up with some idea.
You're down under the water.
Looking at this stuff firsthand.
I've walked the walk,
I've walked the walk.
I've put my,
I put my life on the line and I've made an honest and sincere attempt to provide
some balance to the grotesquely imbalanced picture of our history that is
presented by mainstream archeology.
This is,
this is what I fundamentally see my role as being,
you know,
I'm per portrayed as that by the BBC is this person,
who's selling these wild theories to the public through,
I don't know,
some kind of Glib magic,
but actually what I see myself as is somebody who's saying,
hang on,
there might have been another way.
Things could have been different.
The way that we're being told things where there's enough problems with that to
raise some questions and I'm going to look at those questions and I'm going to
document them and examine them and let's see what they come to.
I do not insist that there was a lost civilization.
I think it's highly probable.
I think it has been missed by the mainstream.
And so what I tried to do was provide balance to a very biased picture,
uh,
rather than try to completely overthrow the picture.
I'm simply trying to balance it and that's never been seen.
And I,
I feel,
I feel in that area I was treated very unfairly.
But Hey,
uh,
the BBC horizon experience was a really good learning experience for me.
I needed my ego taking down a peg or two
and that,
the psychedelic experience in and of itself,
right.
In and of itself.
Yeah.
If you know.
So I was,
I was,
I was ready for,
I'll ask you to kick me up the ass.
Well,
um,
thank you very much for joining us,
man.
I can't thank you enough.
This was such a huge treat for me is,
like I said,
your,
your book,
the fingerprints of the gods really just changed the way I looked at everything
changed the way I looked at human history,
changed the way I looked at the academic study of human history.
And what people are willing to,
you know,
to believe and not believe and how much they're willing to throw everything that
they've learned aside or push it aside or everything that they're teaching.
And it's a,
it's a,
it's amazing.
It's amazing work for people that are skeptical.
You need to just look at some of the photographs.
Look at some of the bell back.
Is that what it's called
now?
That could love it.
Yeah.
10,000 ton megaliths
you just need to see them.
They're in.
It doesn't even,
how tall are they?
They're like insanely tall.
10 feet tall.
Oh No.
Much more than that.
That the huge megalith in Baalbek is going to be a hundred feet long.
A hundred feet long.
One stone,
one stone.
And where was it?
Cut Fries.
More than a thousand tons.
Not Far.
That was quarried quite locally,
but a thousand tons,
you know,
come on.
And what is the explanation?
They academic explanation for that.
They say that that temple was built by the Romans as the temple of Jupiter and
that the Romans moved does big stamps.
I would say that what happened was that,
uh,
a much older culture created that big stone structure and the on top of it,
the Romans built the temple of Jupiter.
So 10,000 plus years ago,
something happened.
I believe so what?
I think it was the end of something.
Uh,
what 12 and a half thousand years ago was the end,
not the beginning.
That was,
that was a,
that was the time when the meltdown of the ice age was at one of his most
extreme periods.
The actual meltdown of the ash took 10,000 years to unfold.
But within that 10,000 years,
there were three or four episodes of gigantic flooding where you had 30 foot
rise of sea levels very rapidly,
virtually overnight.
Um,
you consider what a 30 foot sea level rise would do to our civilization today
would wipe out every coastal city.
I mean,
look,
America is still reeling from Hurricane Katrina.
Imagine what would happen if every coastal city went under 30 feet of water.
Um,
it would is enough to destroy any civilization.
So it was a climate change thing.
You think it was suddenly a climate change,
but,
but you know,
the,
the cataclysmic explanation of m ice caps is to do with the pole shifts and to
do with,
uh,
with the mechanism called Earth crust displacement,
which was first proposed by Charles Hapgood.
And they go into this at some length in fingerprints of the gods.
The notion that that the outer crust of the earth,
rather like the sort of skin of an orange could move around the fruit,
the inner core of the earth,
that the court,
the crust could move.
Uh,
and therefore in hap goods theory,
uh,
ice forms on areas of the crust that are close to one or other pole.
That makes sense.
The polls are cold,
but when the crust shifts,
it moves that cold area into a warm area,
moves it closer to the equator,
makes all the ice,
and meanwhile new eye starts to foam form on the new pole.
Um,
so that theory explains the meltdown of the Ice Age,
not as a result of climate change,
but as a result of cataclysmic earth movements.
And then explains also ancient maps of Iceland.
And Greenland does.
It does.
I think the maps are a very important question,
which I do not see any academic providing a good answer to.
There are maps.
Um,
almost always these maps turn out to be copies of earlier maps.
Uh,
the period is map is a famous example.
He tells he was a Turkish admiral and he tells us actually in hand write his own
handwriting on the fragment of the map that has survived that he based his was a
world map.
We've only got one corner of it that he based it on more than a hundred source
maps,
none of which have survived.
This was the case with the Raunchiest Phineas map and some of the Marketo maps
as well that they were drawing on ancient maps,
which no longer,
which didn't come down to us.
So these maps were drawn within relatively recent history within the last
thousand years,
but they were copying much older maps,
many thousand years,
1000 years older.
And so it's very interesting when we find anomalies on these maps.
For example,
um,
our culture,
uh,
discovered Antarctica in 18,
18,
um,
before that maps that were being drawn around 1800,
they showed an empty hole where Antarctica is.
But if you go back to the 15 hundreds of the 14 hundreds,
when they were copying these older maps,
they haven't come down to us.
You find Antarctica on every single one of them.
That's incredible on every single one of them.
And,
and,
uh,
it's kind of a bit bigger than it is now and it comes close to an almost touches
South America just as it did during the last ice age.
You'll find off the coast of Ireland,
a little circular island with the legend on,
it's called High Brazil.
That island is about 120 miles west of the West Irish coast.
Um,
if you look at sea level rise,
you find that 12,000 years ago and earlier an island of exactly that size and
exactly that shape existed in exactly that spot.
And it was covered by rising sea levels 12,000 years ago.
And it shows up on this math like a ghost.
Um,
and that has to mean to,
to has to mean that somebody was around 12,000 years ago who had at least
developed sufficient technology to explore the world and map it accurately.
And a flood killed all that and a flood destroyed a door.
You're convinced of the flood.
Uh,
like I say,
I'm not,
I'm not here with a belief system.
Um,
I'm [inaudible],
I'm here with anomalies and problems in the mainstream,
in the mainstream model.
And,
and what the evidence suggests to me very,
very strongly is that those cataclysmic earth changes at the end of the ice age.
And even regardless whether a pole Schefter or crustal displacement was
involved,
nobody can dispute that.
The meltdown of the ice age was a cataclysmic event.
Will,
I'm sorry,
sorry.
Evolved huge amounts of volcanic activity and it involved these tremendous
releases of water.
So the ice would actually accumulate in glassy lakes for thousands of years.
It would melt slowly,
slowly melt.
And then suddenly this is the mainstream model.
Suddenly the,
um,
the banks of the ice dam that held back that water would burst and the whole
mass of 4,000 years of meltwater would pour down into the world ocean in one
moment.
And,
and,
and the water descending from the top of the ice cap would reach speeds of 600
miles an hour and there were a wave height of close to a thousand feet.
It then tears across the landscape that lies below the ice cap.
And you see this still the scab lands of New Jersey,
the,
the finger lakes of New York state.
These are the results of those massive outburst floods that then tear,
tear across the land and then pour into the water and wash up,
go see level.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
Could you imagine a thousand foot high wave just tearing across the entire
continent?
It happened.
It definitely has.
It definitely happened.
Mainstream sciences,
not in disagreement on how excited were you about the discovery of Atlantis?
Do you buy into that 100%?
Atlantis for me,
um,
is one of,
uh,
thousands of traditions,
about,
uh,
hi episode of Human Civilization in remote antiquity,
destroyed when that civilization angered the gods.
That is a,
that is a universal story.
It's told everywhere.
Um,
and the Atlantis,
the Atlantis story is better understood as part of that worldwide,
uh,
tradition rather than viewed in isolation.
Um,
it's very interesting.
The Atlantis story comes to us from the Greek philosopher Plato.
He is the earliest source of the Atlantis Myth if it's a myth.
And uh,
he sets out information about Atlantis in two of his dialogues that Timmy has
and the Critias.
And what he says is that this information came to him through an elder figure
who's called long like Greek lawmaker,
who existed about a hundred years before the time of Plato,
but was in Plato's family.
And the information had been passed down to Plato so long had received the
information from priests in Egypt.
They'd told him about Atlantis.
This is how Plato tells a story.
And when Plato tells the story,
he actually puts a date on the submergence of Atlantis and that date is 9,000
years before the time of soul on that means 9,600 BC,
that means 11 and a half thousand years ago.
And we're right there in that window when the ice age is melting down and,
and hell is being unleashed on earth.
And uh,
if Plato made it all up,
I'm really,
I really need to understand how he got the date right.
It's amazing.
What a beautiful way of putting it that we are a species with amnesia.
And it's really almost,
I mean,
when you,
when you stop and think about it,
how does one keep records
over 12,
15,000 years with giant cataclysmic events where people are for many generations
scratching and scrounging,
just trying to stay alive like animals,
very difficult.
No
monumental architecture may be one way of doing it.
Um,
the,
you know,
the notion that the pyramids and the Sphinx were laid out on the ground to
muddle in ancient sky and thus define a date using four constellations,
which where Leo Aquarius drug go on a Ryan using those four constellations to
define a date,
it seems like a kind of exotic idea,
but uh,
we have that right here in the United States in the Hoover dam.
Um,
there is a star map built into the architecture of the Hoover dam and that star
map freezes the sky above the Hoover dam.
At the moment the Hoover dam was completed.
Uh,
and the purpose of putting that star map there by the man who originated it was
precisely this.
They said in 10,000 years time,
if our civilization is lost and our language is lost and nobody can read our
documents,
uh,
when they come across the structure by looking at the star map,
they will be able to know when it was created.
Yeah.
Dang.
How crazy is that?
And it's all based on the procession of the Equinox
based on the precession,
which gives you this universal beautifully mathematical cycle.
And we got to think that if people think like that today,
they must have thought like that back down if the civilization had in some
totally different and alien way than our own.
I mean,
so alien that their writing was images,
you know,
Egypt.
That's one of the things I really got out of John Anthony West DVD series was he
really kind of gets you to understand how different their culture and society
was than ours.
The way they,
just,
the way they read things,
they read things,
you know,
it was all like shell,
Nike,
Reebok.
I mean they saw things in images.
That was their language.
Their language was images.
Such a bizarre and different way to even think about existence.
Yeah.
Very different than,
and,
uh,
the important thing for me to remember about the ancient Egyptians is this,
this was a culture that devoted his best minds,
you know,
for 3000 years to considering the mystery of life.
What this is about and the mystery of death.
We lost so much in that burning of the library of Alexandria,
right?
Like,
goodness knows what.
We lost those with the whole heritage of the human rights went down and not so
incredible.
We're left with this framework,
these,
these stone things to try to deconstruct the past.
And,
and even people,
I mean,
they have a certain amount of information and they say,
we're done.
We're done.
We figured it out.
We've figured it out.
Yeah.
Just the idea that they can put a date to it and what haven't they dated the
pyramids just sort of based on carbon and things were left behind.
That doesn't necessarily mean that people did in new vein into the Pyramids at
2,500 BC.
Like do they know the exact date?
There's not,
there's not much to go on.
Um,
it's,
you can't compensate stone,
but you can carbon date organic material and in the mortar between the stones,
there's some organic material and the carbon dating on that is really puzzling.
Um,
it doesn't make the pyramid 12,000 years old,
but it makes,
it makes it a thousand years older than it's supposed to be at the top and 400
years older than it's supposed to be at the bottom.
Go figure that out.
Huh?
You think they build from the bottom up,
not the other way down.
Um,
and this says nothing about the core structure of the pyramid.
It only says about the outer facade.
How does that,
I don't think we can,
I don't think we can take the pyramid away entirely from the ancient Egyptians.
The edge of the Egyptians were massively involved in the pyramid project.
Um,
but I think the pyramid project is one of those two phase projects.
And the,
the view I put forward is that,
uh,
is that the original site was laid out,
around 10,500 BC,
uh,
by the survivors of a lost civilization.
The subterranean aspects of the great pyramid,
the specifically the subterranean chamber was created at that time,
uh,
the gigantic megalithic structures,
the valley temple,
the mortuary,
so called mortuary temples that stand beside the pyramids would pretty seem so
different in terms of their architecture,
which have in some cases,
blocks of stone weighing 200 tons and many blocks of stone weighing 100 tons,
um,
in,
in them that this was the first phase.
And that,
uh,
and that,
that then I would suggest what happened was that those survivors of a lost
civilization,
um,
established something like a monastery at Giza.
Uh,
and then they then started to recruit from the local population so that within a
generation or two,
uh,
they were all Egyptians anyway,
but they were trained in a system of knowledge and that they kept that system of
knowledge close and tight and passed it down for thousands of years.
The idea of knowledge being transmitted for 4,000 years is actually not too
difficult to take.
It's already happened.
We've had that,
we have that with some of our existing religions,
which go back close to 40,000 years.
There's no reason why it shouldn't have happened.
And then at a certain point,
this monastic institution switched Egyptian civilization on with all the high
knowledge that they had preserved.
And that's why it's so perfect at the beginning.
And no one else was able to do that at that time.
Anywhere else in the world.
Not In the way the Egyptians did.
It was quite unique,
just as magical series of events and yeah.
Yeah.
I mean the great pyramid is a magical thing.
Magical.
Yeah.
I managed to climb climate five times.
I've been into every known chamber and,
and Passageway in the grid.
Tell me about the king's chamber because that is the freakiest thing of all.
And for people who don't know,
they've proven that some of the stones in the king's chamber from a core,
how many hundred miles away at close to 700 miles.
So these are like 500 tons.
These giant stones.
How were they,
how
much do they weigh?
The heaviest stones in the pyramid way about 70 times seven,
seven tons.
Those are what you're talking about.
The weight of 35 large family cars,
roughly.
If a large family car weighs two tons,
that's 35 of them in the equivalent of the heavier blocks in the
right.
Yeah.
There's between like two tons and like that
s two tons of 70 Johns.
Is that what it is?
You can,
there's trucks be,
yeah,
yeah.
We can do it.
We can,
we can do it.
But it's hard.
And,
and to do it again and again and again and again and again.
And to do it with incredible precision and to align the whole structure that
you're building within three 60th of a single degree of true north.
That's really to know from that quarry to the Pyramids.
There wasn't a paved road,
there wasn't a highway,
there wasn't gas stations.
These 50 ton blocks of solid granite.
What are they doing?
They put him on boats.
I mean,
how are they getting these things?
you say 700 miles,
not just shipping them.
They would definitely shipping them.
Uh,
down the Nile.
That's what they want.
It's hard to even wrap your head around the fact that people were communicating
from 700 miles away that long ago,
but they were doing it moving giant stones into place for some crazy asshole
that wanted a huge,
that's the people working at the quarry.
This crazy bitch wants a 50 ton rock.
I believe we got to chop this thing up.
The person who tried to talk him out of it at
glisten,
listen that I have a hut.
It's made out of wood.
It's awesome.
You don't need to do this.
The interesting thing is,
you know,
the Egyptians it to devote that kind of architecture edgy today daily lives,
but to,
to their,
their houses were quite simple.
They devoted it to their sacred architecture and they,
they were perfect in everything and everything.
They did.
I come,
I come out of all of this just with a sense of the mystery,
the majesty and the,
all of our last past and,
and the fact that we do need to know who we are and where we came from.
We do need to recover.
Our memories were part of the,
part of the reason we're so fucked up is because we just have got no idea what
the fuck
we've woken up in the middle of history.
Yeah.
Duncan and I were talking about this before.
If there was a time machine with what time would you like to go back?
And we went back and forth from caveman days.
I'd have to see some caveman to Egypt.
I think I'd like to see Egypt.
I would love to see Egypt in its prime to see what the fuck was going on there.
You know how,
what,
what was that like when it was in full bloom and the pyramids had just been
created and just this,
this strange civilization as super advanced civilization had just,
just risen far and beyond anything else on the planet.
Let's build a time machine right now.
And with that note,
thank you very much sir.
It's been an amazing conversation.
A huge honor.
And please fall Graeme on Twitter.
It's a double underscore after Graham g r a h a m double Hancock and you got to
do the double on the score because if you go to single on the store or some
asshole has your name,
do you know Twitter?
We'll give you Graham Hancock if someone has that.
There is another grant Panco cause he had guy.
Yeah.
Oh you should ask him hook you up.
It is.
And the website is grabbed Graham hancock.com and I have my youtube channel.
That's all you have a youtube channel.
And what is that through?
Is links through the website.
Um,
it's Graham hancock.com channel or something like that.
[inaudible] get started on Graham,
if you,
you've got to get this fingerprints of the gods.
It's a,
in one of my all time favorite books.
If I was leaving and going to go on the space station for the rest of my life,
I'd bring that one with me for sure.
It's amazing.
Thank you so much for being here.
I cannot thank you enough.
This has been a amazing treat that the internet has brought us together.
Thank you.
I've really enjoyed our conversation.
Excellent.
Excellent Shit.
Wow.